thank you
[Music]
day
radio
[Music]
switching over let me get some levels
right quick bike check bike check you
know all that good stuff check it out
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello
right now yeah I know the rain in Spain
stays mainly in the plane
we do tongue twisters for the doing our
drama
all right here
and of course we are live and welcome to
the islands podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 292.
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
and today I'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got control
freaked
a Game Pass dominate the future psvr2
reviews and for axis games to discuss so
we gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who's iconic rise is
a young Prodigy within the games
industry is truly a testament to his
immense talent and his daddy dream but
whose unreal contributions truly
elevated him to Rockstar status within
gaming culture
introducing the entrepreneur and
designer of jazz Jackrabbit unreal and
the Gears of War franchise plus author
of The insightful control freak Memoir
the Lord of Epic Adventures in a Mad
World
who turned the needy into the greedy
with great games his success came Speedy
live from North Carolina and kind enough
to make his debut into the realm of the
Lords my man Lord Clifford blazinski AKA
Cliffy B how we doing sir that was that
was quite the introduction actually
thank you very very much try to give me
some iced tea balls to try to give them
something maybe do my Iced Tea voice
I had nothing yeah I wanted it y'all had
everything
into the greedy with my games by success
you see what I'm doing watch me flipping
rip of the freedom tip open your mind to
the point of the ice pick okay okay
first of all how you doing sir
absolutely Legend um
doing my thing these days
um like I was saying earlier I'm
sleeping until noon and uh doing press
appearances whenever I want to and I
wrote a stinking book which I'm
continuing to play everywhere but yes
we didn't notice
it's kind of a cool situation going on
yeah actually going to give a a digital
copy away sometime during the podcast
so but honestly it was almost a deal
breaker with you guys in regards to
doing this podcast and the whole the
whole swearing thing oh yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna act like my little nieces
right here next to me because she called
me out recently she's like I was like
you stinking kids need to get the heck
inside the house and she looks at me and
she goes we're gonna say bad words
[Laughter]
she do what she was capable of now look
man I appreciate look we know slip Step
Up Sound look if Jaffe got through I was
surprised to the end right I would say
he got he gave us like you know what I
used to call him was David Gaffey
dude always his quotes would just be the
most you're like wait Dave what are you
saying now
just like screw the games industry I'm
just gonna go off and do my own podcast
and do my own thing I have enough money
and I'm like that sounds like a good
idea yeah shout out to the legendary
with all the stuff you got going on has
there been any chance to play games
recently and if so what have you been
playing specifically I
um I I played that game where you can
modify the scale of things uh it's got
the weirdest name you just change the
the everything
um I'm so bad um I'm all about my switch
these days oh I love retro Platformers
did you see did you guys see the sales
on the switch by the way yeah oh man
it's it's encroaching on the PlayStation
too for like the number one selling
console yeah I think it overtook them
right now right overall solve or no it
overall it overtook PS4 oh you just
gotta beat DS and PS2 it's ridiculous
yeah so the other thing what what has my
attention right now there's this
version of this game called Cleopatra's
Fortune I don't know if you've ever seen
it it was like a 1990s Puzzler game
right and it's kind of like Tetris but
in it's actually slightly harder but for
some reason I find it therapeutic and
like you know there I don't know if you
guys saw that trailer for the tetris
movie yeah like attic watched it I have
said it before and I'll say it a million
times Tetris is the greatest game of all
wait can you repeat that
and I knew that I I fell in love with my
wife when we went to Mexico on a
vacation and we both had a Nintendo DS's
and she she taught me what a t-spin was
because they they added that to Tetris
later on I think they kind of flip it
around and and it was one of those
things where she whipped my butt at
first and I was like I have to marry I
have to marry me
gonna get into we got a lot to talk
about you already know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those original Lords
of the realm here at the round table
with some time sensitive intros because
we try to maximize that's right at it
time King
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show future
Tetris lover how we doing sir
doing pretty good man I've been playing
a lot of Hogwarts Legacy uh it's a very
unique game I'm starting to see his
flaws a little bit stuff starting to
annoy me more and more the more I play
but I still really enjoyed the game and
that's what I'm gonna you know
appreciate uh Cliffy for coming on it's
gonna be a great podcast and I'm gonna
cut there because uh King gonna probably
take people
make sure the mic you're on is there
yeah
super premium they're crispy and
um don't don't pop don't pop the peas
and of course does that sound better yes
yes there we go and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
game who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the soft
straddamus the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bank my man Lord
Sovereign how we doing sir I'm doing
fantastic I uh only thing I played this
week is a Metroid Prime remastered yes
that I need to get oh brother it's like
a new game it is a remaster because they
haven't touched the source code but it
looks like a modern game and it plays
like you the moment they gave you just
regular controls analog controls
and and that's default now forget it it
plays like a different game you don't
need to lock onto anything you could
play it like Halo
um yeah the lock-on was a hack right
yeah so yeah now forget it man it really
is kind of you can see how special it is
now really so that's what I've been
playing
um yeah we we watched the Ant-Man
Quantum Mania last night
I know it's you know how you know how
this once every three months
it's usually a Marvel movie yeah of
course of course news aren't that good
for it by the way yeah all right the
reviews are bad I don't know I will just
say we enjoyed it generally as a group I
just think it felt like it kind of it
was weird for an Ant-Man movie to be
that bombastic and feel kind of like a
Star Wars movie yeah a lot of tropes
yeah a lot of tropes in there and then I
just also felt like Kang's the strength
of Kang and the fact that he's supposed
to be this big bad overall for this
entire sort of Arc of the of the MCU
it didn't it didn't feel like it came
through okay in in this movie but I made
overall I enjoyed I I wasn't mad at the
time I spent with it like okay I can't
wait to see it I think it when it comes
to that movie it's like I thought it was
a good movie but I can understand why
people didn't yeah no yeah absolutely I
get it and Shout Out shout out to Lord
meds brother had an accident yesterday
after after we all left each other yeah
he's okay but he hurt his leg uh
yeah you know magic always use was that
that thing he uses that unicycle thing
yeah
really it's a death train it is listen
it's not even a scooter he's where he
has a real unicycle yeah it's one of
those elections how hipster is this man
I told him too the last time hopefully
he's in the chat somewhere listen to him
he's like he's like man I can't do that
Segways or Play-Doh
he's a super adrenaline
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the excess gamer the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
I'm doing fantastic now that I have the
Creator
oh
yeah but Marcus Phoenix in the building
I want to see what's in that shelf
behind you eventually oh man I'll
definitely send you some pictures I'm
not seeing Decepticons there am I or oh
no no I don't know
I gotta speak a little in on that again
team Autobot here oh yes for sure oh
definitely for sure no Decepticons
it's not the cons to be snitching they'd
be snitching man I was a little kid with
the construct the cause first cave and I
saw a Devastator I was mind blown I like
the Predacons because yeah
that was when they were actually die
cast metal right yup remember that I was
having the same conversation I said I
remember when they made the switch over
from toys that can kill you to toys that
can probably hurt you and um yeah that's
the thing like you know they used to be
able to like shoot things out because
yeah idiot kid in Ohio like shot his eye
out there for everyone
glasses yeah Cliffy I saw you with that
barrage man yes
I I just I grew up with Transformers and
I'll always get Transformers I have in
my my lower level what I call my Optimus
Shrine
Optimus for those of us of our age I
don't know how old you guys are about it
we're all in the same pocket exception
okay well Optimus looks like our dad you
know and then sitting there in the
theater it was like 1986-87 yeah oh yo
Cliffy I still cry bro I was they they
tortured kids like kids were not ready
for what was when you see the smoke
leaving their mouth and I'm like oh my
God
they're dying yo no what happened was
the way they would die my cousin and I
are such a week yes we cut school to go
to see the movie and this is gonna be my
segment okay we cut school to go see the
movie and I was the whole time this is
the first time I cut school and I was
like this is bad this is bad but We
snuck inside the Whitestone movie
theater
sadness satin quiet sitting down in the
movie started and they would started
killing Transformers yo
no so okay what I've been playing this
week fortnite uh high five rush you said
the f word
that's the real curse word here Kane
it's a bad curse word
also also I've been playing The Last of
Us uh re remastered and The Last of Us
Part One
right I know it sounds stupid but I was
going back to see the differences right
just because we doing the show too
it's incredibly well done and yeah this
is what happens when you have the game
creators involved as well as like uh
like the people who worked on that great
show Chernobyl right and they just right
they come together and because I mean
you know naughty dog has just been the
masters of making like cinematic gaming
experiences right and yeah it's just
it's such such a good show and who
doesn't love Pedro Pascal oh
you're just such a likable dude I
remember seeing in the Comic-Con got a
few years ago at a party and he was you
know having a few drinks and just but
just loving the attention like he was
getting from playing the uh it was the
Viper the Viper yeah I was telling attic
about it but yeah
Oberyn Martell yeah he was also in Law
and Order at one point or like he was
the dude's been acting free he was over
a long time he was actually he was
actually on Buffy the vampires when
Buffy
though
I was going back and forth with that uh
just seeing um if anybody's on the fence
with getting the PlayStation version of
part one get off the fence and just just
go get it
um it's such a technological achievement
yes it's using the same type of
techniques that they use for part two uh
the last of us too and I think you know
lots of us too for me is probably like
one of my all-time favorite games so uh
really if you're on the fence just go do
it and I got I picked it up don't you
love those much as good as the TV show
is there's moments where they're kind of
emulating the game a little bit where
it's like I'm gonna push this thing over
here so you can climb through this yeah
yeah
I'm like waiting for like a quick time
event to pop up
that's it for me that's no doubt of
course we have to get rid of himself the
Shinobi law Incognito spreading that
rental center around the IOP not telling
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear for me it's been our destiny
season of The Sound just finished that
shout out to Bungie one of the best
ending transitions to the new season of
life fall and kind of hit you with the
fields with what's about to happen they
kind of have a little Infinity War
moment you know what I'm saying so let's
go to them I've been rocking that
Midnight Sun shout out to the legendary
Jake Solomon for axis games I see y'all
I support it I support I play the
Deadpool DLC just finished that and I
think Venom's dropping uh next week so
I've been doing that and um yeah and
that's a part of the whole package when
you got the season pass or something
yeah yeah so they dropping characters
and they at least have like story
missions how do you go get them out
because I paid for this thing yeah it
couldn't gets convoluted you got to go
to once you go into the Microsoft store
you got to make sure that the add-on is
downloaded and then sometimes it doesn't
install on the back I just said I was
like bro I bought Deadpool where's my
Deadpool family I hate sacrifice five
virgins
I'm old enough to remember when it was
it was DLC or it was just add-on packs
now it's like season four I'm like okay
it's like when apps like programs became
apps it's like yeah it's all it's all
the same stuff it's just a matter of how
they monetize it because everything is a
service now but we was fighting against
it but we was fighting against nothing
because the tide just overtook us so
it's pretty much it so if you want to
set the Rules of Engagement super chat
before we get started me yeah guys so uh
we have a cliff for a limited amount of
time so we want to maximize that time as
much as possible so I will read all
super chats afterwards there are a
couple that are directed right at Cliff
do you want me to just read those but
then yeah yeah that's true yeah
I've been
[Laughter]
okay let me just let me see just read
the ones that directed towards uh yeah
we actually have a a pretty pretty
what's what I'm looking for reasonable
chat clip yeah
you're the Magic Bullet to fix gears you
know you know that's coming
so let me read hardgate Cindy shout out
to Hardy Cindy uh ten dollars salute to
the Lords and welcome to the realm the
legend Cliffy bead and he put in a bunch
of codes for the realm thank you once
again he got Bullet Storm in there he's
got Gears Ultimate Edition
yeah Hogwarts Deluxe so shout out to you
appreciate you brother no doubt no doubt
I snatched up that hard work
it looks real it's really solid yeah
then we have free R Kelly oh
yeah
we've been doing this for quite some
time
some years of free R Kelly
Cliff did you guys ever anticipate the
shotgun in Gears would determine the way
the game was played in multiplayer no we
never anticipated that because I mean
it's literally on the box that it's the
Lancer it's a chainsaw gun game it's a
chainsaw gun game and then when you give
players the ability to explode people in
a second they're going to take that
ability yeah so wound up becoming a
shotgun game and we fought that for
years until by the time Gears 3 came
around uh lee Perry it was my
co-designer on it right he's like let's
let's do a sauna shotgun and you can
just make like five people explode at
once and I'm like ship it that sounds
great
I mean it's proof of like you know at
some point you have to give the people
what they want yeah right you can fight
it all you want but then you know it's
kind of go see a band you know like you
go see like and get showing my age going
to see like Def Leppard you know you
want to hear the old school songs you
know you want to hear Pour some sugar on
me you don't want to hear the new stuff
right so exactly so you just you know
gotta listen to the listen to the
audience and the wisdom of the crowd as
they say respect exactly
two more two more five dollar super chat
with you B is Xbox's David Jaffe welcome
to the realm
yeah and then we have
where the heck was this one Cliffy and
gears defined this is Simon uh Brandy
with the five pound Super Chat cliffian
gears defined the 360 era for me there's
no showman gaming anymore and nobody
like clip Phil should tempt him back
amicable you know he still slides into
my DMs once in a while
let's go that's why he's Aurelius the
thing is is uh the gaming companies and
powers that be don't want there to be
any video game rock stars anymore
because and like you know the last
remaining one is Kojima Kojima yeah yeah
correct you're correct and so like you
know I I enjoyed stepping out of the
spotlight for quite some time because it
gets nasty out there and is it just me
or is it it feels like gaming has gotten
like exponentially more toxic in the
last like yeah yeah oh yeah
definitely ask you details about that
and how you feel about it yeah people
losing the fun you can say whatever you
want to me you just you say something
about my family or my wife and yeah this
isn't coming for you you know thanks of
course the game I mean it comes from
Passion
they say the crap because they care
true but I just feel like social media
we gonna get into it but we allow people
to social stuff that they wouldn't say
that nobody faced I gotta I got a
question for Clifford
um and the only reason why I call him
Cliff is because of the book uh because
I was ignorant coming in going calling
Cliffy B now it's Clifford
um what is this uh Android versus iPhone
thing oh come on yeah I don't know what
it is
this thing with my my whole my in-laws
right right Louisiana in laws they all
have iPhones right right and except for
my brother-in-law he's an engineer and
he has an Android right and so we have
that group that group text thing right
yeah right and there's the green bubble
and there's the blue bubble
and it's like like I've seen images from
dating apps where women are like if you
have an Android I won't date you oh wow
serious thing have you seen
two if you're not at least five eleven I
won't date you yes what what is going on
out there because and so like you know
same thing you know I'm transitioning to
my friend who's single right he's a
handsome dude he's tall and I was on I
was on he's on like Tinder Bumble and
hinge right and I'm like I'm looking at
all of it I'm like oh it is horrible out
there terribly
yeah so I just I I okay
I had no idea because somebody when I
put up the promo he was like please
please ask him about the Android versus
iPhone thing I'm like what's going on I
think I have like an S8 or I don't know
like yes I'm with you I got I got a
Android my wife's like you need to
upgrade your phone I'm like does it
works in games as long as I did I'm like
do not add any variables here
exactly there you go that's that's the
producer in my head it's like okay we
can just add this one more feature three
weeks before too much feature creep
right exactly exactly foundationally we
work my old my old producer Rod Ferguson
so many gears games he's one of the best
producers I've ever worked with
um he said he used to say don't shake
the jello you know like it's the
butterfly effect you know that terrible
ass picture movie you know like one
thing can change a million things in
software development which is why I'm
like the same thing is like when it
comes to like the internet in our house
I'm like is it working don't move don't
move yeah
let's think about solid state
Electronics like you know we have like
multiple Alexis in our house and it'll
just crash I'm like you've just been
sitting there listening you had one
stinking job
you know everything requires a reboot
like this very PCM on with you it's my
rvr PC this used to be our fancy little
dining room right and we're like we're
never gonna use that in the crappy China
behind us so let's just make it VR space
you know and then this is our my PC for
you know podcast to interviews because
you know my wife started to do the
streaming thing yeah office is all over
there so we wanted to kind of be the
other space I got the little like the
ring light too oh okay yeah okay all
right 48 years old I'm still getting
acne
that it keeps us young Cliff I don't
mind the pimple here and there I'm good
as long as you don't get one in your
junk I don't know what that's like yeah
right
down to Florida
do you guys follow uh do you fall
Florida man on Twitter
it's basically like story after Story of
like Florida man Florida man something
fornicating with neighbors Chihuahua
one after another I swear to God it's
the best Twitter account yeah it's worse
than the Bronx uh so I'm gonna close off
the Super Chat because you know they're
gonna keep going yeah keep going so
we'll close them off we'll read the rest
afterwards right you guys appreciate it
down so that we got into what the Lord's
been playing all that good stuff we
gotta focus on Lord Clifford his video
game system history his journey into
game development at epic games and of
course creating the iconic unreal and
Gears of War franchises and then leading
to this powerful personal Memoir control
freak so look let's start from the very
beginning let's come to the first video
game systems you had what got you into
gaming it was the Atari 2600. we all had
that one like neighbor like kid that was
spoiled and they got all the toys before
everything okay was that for me like I
would go over there to free load and
second hand continue yep yep in my own
heart director from epic he actually
recently retired from epic um he
basically told me like what you know
when he had kids he he made the coolest
house possible with all the good toys so
he would know what the kids are up to so
they're not like at the the cool parents
house drinking beer in the basement when
they're like 12 years old right yeah
um and so this this friend of mine um he
had the Atari 2600 and I must have been
six or seven years old and I went over
there and I I played Space Invaders and
just being able to move an image on the
screen to me just resonated with me and
you know I had other things I wanted to
do for a while you know I wanted to do
the acting thing for a while I wanted to
be a herpetologist because I like you
know reptiles and amphibians and things
like that but video games just spoke to
me and I once I realized that not only
could I move things on the screen I
could be the one who's making the things
on the screen that was that was that was
Hook Line and Sinker just non-stop and
then you know I I got the adventure
construction kit on my Atari uh no no
not my target it was on my uh my Apple
TC and then you know I made like little
adventure games with that and then
eventually I learned how to do basic and
Visual Basic and just kicked and
screamed and clawed my way into the
business and uh you you learned that on
your own yeah self-taught you know I
went to I went to Cal Poly Pomona for
about six months and then I dropped out
because I honestly think college is a
huge racket
my wife and I are one of our favorite
pubs last night there's a March Madness
going on and some guy was like who are
you rooting for and I'm like no college
is a record are those kids getting paid
yet by the way soon some of them are
yeah that's happening it's happening can
they even put their names in their
uniforms yet like come on but they're
getting an education at Duke yeah yeah
exactly so um but but I just you know
games spoke to me and the thing about
working in video games for 25 years is
it actually Jade me a fair amount to the
point where like you know when you know
how to make video games all you see is
the dollar signs on the screen like you
know this is incredible as The Last of
Us in Uncharted those kinds of games God
of War you know Sony Santa Monica and
all that naughty dog like those games
cost a ton of money to make and a ton of
man hours and for me I just that's why I
love just like simple little like games
like Shovel Knight you know just like
yeah I love the Retro stuff these days
you know the the you know and I'm you
know I'm not actually playing the new uh
you know Hogwarts Lacey but I'm watching
my wife play it on stream and there's
times where it looks amazing and there's
times where it doesn't look so amazing
and that's the thing is when you make
these games with 8 million developers in
in 16 Studios you know it's the quality
can be right here or it can kind of go
here and that's that's a part of my
brain that I'm just happy to kind of
disengage with for a while but so you
want to take it back to how Jazz
Jackrabbit is like that's the thing is I
I actually wanted to make a spiritual
sequel to Jazz did you guys PlayStation
one do you guys ever play the game
jumping flat yes of course oh that
game's amazing yes right that was the
first game that I ever played that
actually solved first person platform
yep because nine times out of ten if
you're in a first person game and you're
doing platforming it's terrible you
can't judge where you're just a distance
exactly because when you're in third
person you have the shadow of the
character you can tell we're gonna land
and things like that right but to do
something like that in first person to
do it properly I think would be
incredibly compelling just like Duke
Nukem started as a 2d platform game that
eventually became a first person shooter
right and then kind of went off into a
weird Direction but that's Duke no no I
agree okay so you went from Atari 2600
you went to the Apple what was was it
any other console that was one console
oh then it was that it was Nintendo
obviously here we go let's go so the I
had another neighbor on the street and
he was uh a couple years younger than I
but he got the Nintendo Entertainment
System he had robbed you know but
remember the robot yeah yeah we use it
he had he had the zapper before they
changed it and made it like uh uh orange
or something yeah and I remember like
just you know when Mario first booted up
and just that music kicked in just the
first time I jumped in and hit that
invisible block I was just I was hooked
it was just such a phenomenal experience
then eventually I cheated on Nintendo
like oh let's talk about this fling
let's talk about this yeah let's talk
about this
I wound up getting a Sega Genesis that's
right oh man
you cheated with your chest
okay so the Nintendo part you didn't own
one per se
my dad was an engineer for Polaroid
outside of Boston and um you know he he
was actually you know we raised upper
middle class and my dad you know I'm the
youngest of five boys so my dad was able
to buy us some Transformers and biased
you know you know our first computer and
and all these games and things like that
um but yeah you know for me just
cracking the code of how I can actually
you know get into this industry how I
can make my own stuff and then you know
share where it came around when I
eventually wind up with an IBM 386 SX
that's big talk Japanese yep and then
you know a little game like Wolfenstein
came along and that was after Commander
Keane and I was just like I didn't like
the world in which I lived so I wanted
to make my own virtual world essentially
right because at this time okay so me
reading the book and I know we're going
to get into the book later but uh I was
growing up being bullied too at certain
points because I was too tall for my age
right so I'm 11 years old but I got 15
16 old you know grown kids bothering me
yeah and now that now that's an asset
like you want to be tall yeah but um so
it was uh I was a Nintendo nerd at this
point in time and I I know about the you
know you're getting off the school bus
and running my story and it hit me up it
hit me hard
um my question is you're playing and
then the Nintendo championships because
I know eventually because I was like we
can't let him gloss over there
please use my Champion let's go right um
and okay so that's why I was hearing
that you got them in the Nintendo
how how much man hours did you play
because you was really really really
good like I mean like ungodly good at
Nintendo uh could you talk about that
whole experience in there and get into
the Championships and that's just a rock
star from there I have no idea how I
found the time back in the day yeah
because it's like
like when I think about like when I was
a teenager like I was working at
McDonald's I was playing video games
like a demon like I was in the drama
club I was the lead in multiple plays
and still managed to get eight hours of
sleep a night like I don't know how that
could well because I wasn't dating
um yeah it just there's just something
about the interactive experience that
just always has spoken to me and I
literally saw games as a conquest you
know the whole legend of the high score
and how you know to see my name in
Nintendo Power Magazine
which is framed upstairs in my house and
then it was like it was just it wasn't
enough to to play the games and beat
them I had to understand the systems I
had to figure out how to make you know
my first games were 2D adventure games
you know the point-and-click style ones
and then you know I did Jazz jackrabbit
and Jazz Jackrabbit too I still have an
old sticker here for that I don't know
that's fire and then it was like okay
now we're gonna learn 3D I'm gonna learn
the unreal editor we're going to make my
own levels for you know unreal and then
Unreal Tournament uh and then everything
beyond that and then but not it wasn't
just a matter of that it was like if my
yearbook literally says good luck with
the video gamer acting thing and somehow
I figured out a way to do both by being
this spokesman for epic for many many
years where I I worked in the games I
made my my fair share of what I could do
but it wasn't just enough of that I had
to actually like go into 8 million
interviews and do press tours and things
like that I had to be the you know the
hype man the spokesman company and it
was a lot of freaking work and you know
it's it's funny when I first started
dating Lauren God it's been together for
over 13 years and she'd sit there during
these you know during these press
drunkets and just hear you know they'd
ask me the same five questions over and
over again like how many weapons are in
the new game and I just eventually just
get bored and be like there are no new
weapons
and it was always those like Austin
translation moments when I would be
interviewed by like a Japanese a
Japanese journalist where they've asked
me a question you know like what's the
theme of the game and I'd say something
for like 30 seconds and they they turn
to the journalist the translator and
they'd be like and I'm like I said a lot
more
or they'd be like how many how many guns
are there I'm like 12. then they turn
into and then the translator would talk
for like 40 seconds I'm like
I'm trying to see the equivalency yeah
right it's not balancing out here again
I I think the era of the Rockstar game
designer is kind of dying and it's kind
of sad you know because I think you know
uh the the people the powers that be
that have the money and own and control
these Studios they don't want there to
be one person seen as them because it
very much is a team effort yeah you know
so whenever you see an update for
valorent or Apex Legends or fortnite
it's signed by the team right you know
Donald mustard is the main creative
behind fortnite but not a lot of people
know that right and he was the one you
know responsible for Infinity Blade for
shadow complex
um and he's he's uh he's a creative
genius but he's also incredibly
charismatic the kind of guy that can
stand in front of a room and sell you on
an idea
I thought you was epic like it was it
was a time where I just only thought
like you were that right there I mean
that was that was my plan
was well executed because I saw the
Lamborghini
here we go here we go you know what
because
no because all right so he goes from
this Apex right he transforms himself
from this Apex and then when he
transforms himself into Cliffy B
I'm like this guy he's he's God right
now right he he kicks in the door
because this is at the precipice where
video games are starting to become cool
he made it cool facts right you you
kicked in the door with this this crazy
game and I know we're gonna like
probably gloss over the game in history
and you know you're trying to say good
and stuff but you kicked in the door
you're at the Pinnacle let's say
financially you're not like the the top
apex predator but you are seen as the
apex predator how is that feeling to you
like from from that moment to being you
were the face of cool it went to my head
honestly you know I you know with
between the earrings and the cars and
right you know the thing is you know
like uh the dating and whatnot like
I've always loved being a big fish in a
small pond in our little town of Raleigh
North Carolina and you know I I was
married a while back this is all in the
book and you know I had a really crazy
Affair and then that led to me getting a
divorce and losing all of my unreal
money
um and then and then I was you know
living in our little downtown Raleigh
which is like our little party district
and it was just way too easy to just
date anyone I could but you know to be
like that's the guy that made that that
gods of Warcraft
and he drives he drives the Lamborghini
and I'm like actually it's two of them
but yeah
this is my Tuesday
was pocket watching but that's that's
how I knew that one of the many uh
moments when I knew Lauren was my
forever person where I took her to my my
white Lamborghini and she goes she goes
that's that's cute what's that and she
she didn't know what it was you know
because she wasn't she wasn't a gold
digger at all you know she didn't she
only knew who program Gamers were she
didn't who any of the game developers
were that's actually the transition
slightly the world to which we live now
it's like we're in a world of twitch
streamers YouTubers and and only fans
and people
and then you stop firing women who are
on only fans from their regular jobs
because they're paying them enough in
their regular jobs they wouldn't have to
do all they wouldn't have to do only
fans right
don't don't suck shame these women
I'm just honestly when it comes to the
cars thing I respect cars I I like them
but I'm totally over it like I mean you
get to the point in your life when you
hit over 30 or 40 where you want assets
that are appreciated and don't
appreciate right very very few cars you
know appreciate and value and some but
some people get like the car bug you
know I have some friends of mine that I
worked with back in the day that have a
bazillion of these kind of supercars and
all that and I'm like you know can I
just get some land
I want to back up just for a second and
um with with unreal and epic and I would
probably want to set saw up there
because like the part of the way of you
visualized you coming in the game was
like the young upstart I'm coming I'm
coming for the top dudes like you know
Carl MC Romero you know what I'm saying
in the unreal and the Quake energy like
was your mindset kind of like yo that's
the enemy in a sense and I'm the new I'm
coming from yeah it all comes back to
iced tea honestly I had nothing and I
wanted it you had everything and you
find it right and that was the thing is
you know seeing the you know the wired
articles about you know uh Carmack and
Romero from it and how they had you know
these crazy cars and mansions and things
like that and I was like you know I
looked up to them but I wanted to to
throne them yeah and the kicker was is
you know like I just I was just
listening to to you know so much West
Coast hip-hop at that time you know and
just for some reason like iced Tea's
music just resonated with me and then
years later when I was like able to like
cast him in Gears that's full circle
bro well that was the the story that I'd
love to share in the book is you know we
were at uh at E3 you know and Lauren and
I are hanging out with Ice and Coco all
right and Coco shows up in her very
sheer outfit
and she was super sweet she smelled like
sunless tanner
and her little strap falls down and boom
big just big fleshy Avalanche Falls okay
hello surprise what was Ice's face is
just work in the room right but Lauren
looks over and she's like uh Coco um the
figure yeah and Coco's like happens all
the time sweetie and she caught up
before like everyone was taking photos
or anything like that but the kicker was
I put that story in the book and I had
to get ice T's approval for that story
so I email him in his email and uh I
hear you know he's probably on the set
of Law and Order you know he's in 4 000
or whatever with you know dick
he didn't produce your dick
the most aggressive name
Law and Order 2048 exactly but I hear
back like within like five minutes I
hear absolutely
the kicker was he was playing all of my
games while he was doing his you know
you know his rap career body count and
his acting career like while I was
listening to his music so it was it was
very like meta and then you know the the
old adage they say never meet your
Heroes and I'm like no like most of the
heroes and celebs that I've met have
actually been really cool right you know
as long as you're somebody who does
something interesting or creative at all
yeah you know and that's the thing is
like you know just the fact that you
know I can just like text and be like yo
ice what's going on I'm just like what
okay that's crazy
that's actually like I became friends
with Karen Gillen
um from Guardians of the Galaxy and she
has some app that she's pitching and
wants to hear my feedback on I'm like
okay nebula
you even did that with agree with those
people so I'll set you up because I I
got more questions about what
don't maybe go down the Game of Thrones
I know I think for me it's just
when you really think about your career
clip like everything everything that we
consider to be the norm and whether like
the modern gaming Lance landscape or
just in general Tech wise it was all
happening around what you guys were
doing like it we grew up in a very kind
we're very lucky that all of this sort
of modern tech was starting to come into
its own when we're coming up like how
did you feel with all this stuff going
on around I know you mentioned the book
like you know big big world events
happening at the same time as I just
I'll never forget the first time uh my
producer for jazz Jackrabbit showed me
the unreal editor oh and he says this is
going to be big and I you know at the
time I was using the Jazz Jackrabbit
editor you know right it makes jazz in
the Jazz too but then it was like okay
this 3D space so maybe I can learn this
because I tried 3D Studio Max and I was
not very good I didn't weld my vertices
enough
and then but then you know the thing the
the one of the keys to what Tim Sweeney
understood was making these tools easy
for creatives yes so that you could you
know facilitate the vision it's you know
a better paintbrush right and then make
you know make it because there's so many
friction points there's so much going on
with game development that if you can
make it easy for your average person who
has an idea and has a vision and there's
um a person that I'm slowly working on a
movie project with and he has a saying
where he says and it's a pretty common
saying where it says sometimes you just
will things into existence right and you
know that's the thing is like you know
I'm like okay now I'm going to write a
book and you know I'm working on a comic
book as well and you know I'm going to
produce stuff on Broadway and then you
know the restaurants and when you
realize you know this is one of those
moments you know we were talking earlier
about Manhattan and New York it's you
know I remember thinking New York was
such a big scary place and then years
later learning to love it and realizing
it's all just systems interacting into
the entire world everything is systems
and if you can figure out those systems
you can you know you know like learn the
Matrix because I firmly believe we're in
The Matrix
the Unreal Engine kind of shaped things
and and from the standpoint of then
licensing it out getting you know a fee
and other people utilizing this kind of
standard yeah um
when you look at Epic now right it's a
little bit disappointing to you that
they kind of don't make games anymore
they just it there it kind of feels like
it's a fortnight and unreal machine
I mean
okay oh
technically I'm still under NDA okay
okay so never mind but the thing is you
know they they you know they have to go
where the money is right you know and
fortnite's making it's been making money
hand over fist for years now at this
point right and there was a time period
where you know I like go to the state
fair or I'd go to the mall and I just
see fortnite stuff everywhere and just
got it was really frustrating for a
while because you know epic was very
good to me you know they took care of me
fiscally but it's not like certain other
Industries where if you leave you get
residuals off things like I don't I
don't see a dialogue fortnite even
though I worked on it in like the very
earliest phases and that you know
business is business it is what it is
but right
um I think epic to some extent has kind
of become like valve that's what I
that's the the comparison that I make
where is like they have so much money
you would think you you could make
whatever you want but you decide kind of
not to and I mean that's the thing is
like you know if if I was still in
charge over there of creatively I would
make sure that there are multiple
projects being incubated right because
you know yes fortnite they've done a
fantastic job with keeping this a live
service they have updates after updates
and seasons and battle passes and all
that stuff right but the thing is is it
is it always going to be Evergreen is it
always going to be cool yeah right and
so I just if I was a creative working in
that environment you know there's the
Cash Cow of that but just take 10 people
10 of your best game developers and just
put them in a room I mean that's what
birthed fortnite in the first place was
essentially you know the remnants of the
game Jam right right you know the same
thing with valve you know like you never
know where the next big thing is going
to come from so you know for me
creatively if I were to make another
game you know I'd love to just give me a
team of you know five or six people and
let's just prototype stuff and let's
just let's just find the fun let's feel
it out you're panning for gold at that
point right okay so that um that ability
to think outside of just the one cash
did that come from boss Keys thinking
that you if if you were to hit with uh
one game boss key and it would have
continued to make you know whatever
bread let's say you know boss key would
have made fortnite right let's say you
you get in that cash cow would you have
still have this same thought process I I
would hope so I mean like you want to
get to that point in life where you
don't have to worry about your bills
right you know and if you get to the
point where you're a billionaire I
believe that you have it on your
conscience to do some really good in the
world and actually like change things
you know like as opposed to just buying
Twitter and being an [__]
wearing my birthday balloons
they used to respect the hell out of
that guy I know I just think he's
terrible but anyway
um it's one of those things that uh you
know the whole boss key thing like I
wanted my own game Studio I wanted to be
the one in charge right one of the many
mistakes I made with that studio was
only getting law breakers out the door
initially they took us like nearly three
years to make and like what I should
have done was start started with a team
of like 10 to 20 people and me just a
small little thing and put it out there
you know like figure out how to work
together as opposed to you know the
problems I hired so many talented AAA
developers that they were stuck in that
triple a developer you know mindset that
we couldn't make something like
Minecraft you know like you look at
Minecraft like I remember like my office
mate Allen back in the day at Epic he
was showing me Minecraft and I'm looking
at this like this looks like [__]
this this looks like doo-doo
it was engaged it was engaging and then
you look at like also by the way you
look at traditionally when a studio or
or an IP or game like that gets acquired
by a mega publisher like an EA or
Microsoft they usually drive it into the
ground Microsoft has done a tremendous
job of maintaining Minecraft as a
cultural phenomenon because that game
like you could just take any
eight-year-old and put them on it and
they will figure it out and they will
learn it right and it's just still to
this day utterly compelling kind of like
Counter-Strike Counter-Strike my opinion
is still the best first person shooter
ever oh yeah
Cog I apologize it's gonna ask one more
no please
there's something that he mentioned
specifically about boss key and law
Breakers yes
um in the in in the book you talk about
how you know before you went out on this
endeavor you went to rod
and uh and Rod said I'd love to come on
with you but it's going to be me and you
thing and at that moment you were like
no I want it to be it's a me thing like
I wanted I want to be straight up in
charge
uh if if you guys have been able to work
that out and sort of work in
collaboration knowing how Rod is you
know the closer and somebody who can
kind of keep focus at a game Studio do
you think things would have been
different at Bosque
uh absolutely
um I still again like I said earlier I
think broad is uh hands down if not one
of the best producers in the video game
industry and he's like he's a hardcore
workaholic and he somehow makes it makes
the balance work I don't know how he
does it
um but broad always kept me honest Rod
would you know Rod like people act like
I was just the guy on Gears no it was
the combination
myself working with Rod Ferguson working
with Chris Perna working with Lee Perry
working with Ray Davis
all these other developers we were like
the Beatles
and you have to have that kind of
grouped like Synergy but you know the
thing about bands is bands can't always
last forever true you know the you know
eventually Yoko shows up okay
yeah no I mean the thing is I deep down
a part of me misses making games you
know and the thing is I'm still doing
things creatively you know you'll see
some news in the next few months of some
stuff yeah one of the biggest highs for
me as a creative is typing up a
description okay it's it's a a world
that's an alien planet and then you set
it to a concept artist and then a few
days later you get like a sketch of it
and then you know I sit there and I I
turn my phone I show Lauren I'm like oh
my God that's exactly what I was
thinking you know like that's Beauty I
gave me brother right there but then
when people you make something that is
such an impact on people that they'll
actually get tattoos in their body of it
yeah crazy speaking of which
because he's talking about the tattoos
he's talking about those moments in
gaming we've got to talk about your
magic brother we've got to talk about
you know you this young kid the earrings
the hair step it on that stage in
Hollywood you know this is Microsoft's
big IP a lot of pressure you know and
then we're talking about Halo at the
time gets delayed for the 360. so it
wasn't necessarily ready there's a lot
of pressure on Gears coming in you know
this big IP from epic so I want you to
paint that picture give me the energy of
the studio coming in like did you know
you had it and then going on that stage
where let's be honest
everything could go wrong this is you're
from it actually does yeah and you're
from where remember we're from the ERA
King where it's really the vertical
slice BS let's be let's be real right
where dudes don't grab that controller
and really do that thing and Cliff is up
there with one of these you know 360
yeah you know and he's out there so like
paint the picture leading up to that
moment and then the moment itself how
was that I was uh going through the
separation of divorce with my first wife
at the time when I was living in a
really cheap apartment like basically a
stone's throw from epic and everything
was riding on my shoulders at that point
um I had a new girlfriend at the time
and she was very supportive and it was
one of those things that if I had known
like how important that moment would be
for the rest of my life I might not have
been able to have delivered but I was
young enough and cocky enough to been
like screw it I could do this you know
and I I I credit that to my my drama
upbringing like you know I grew up with
Saturday Night Live always on you know
like I watched I watched Carson and then
Leno with my parents right before every
night before bed and you know the
ability to step on stage and to be a
public figure to put to put yourself out
there and you know you get that little
nervous thing in your stomach right and
you're about to do something you haven't
done and you know there's a phrase that
I also like it says do one thing every
day that scares you yeah and if you can
take that knot in your belly and turning
that into motivation I think it's a
beautiful thing and that's why you know
I just I love doing like karaoke at
least like once a week you know
very mediocre at it
that was a seminal moment to establish
myself as a public figure as face of
Epic for that for the foreseeable future
and the internet loves it and they hate
it they love to build the up and they
love to tear you down you know and so I
think that's only here in America but go
ahead well I mean the entire internet
loved it when bosky folded by the way no
we didn't I didn't well but he's right A
Lot the internet
they don't like cocky like that devs is
the only like genre you can't be the
cocky devs for some reason did you read
that quote for me because I've said that
in every other medium if you can be you
could be a politician you could be a
musician you could be whatever you could
be cocky right
um when if you're a Game Dev no you
can't you can't be confident I don't
know what it is I championed you
for that like because all right
we we came from and you remember it
where video games were shunned right and
I guess that whatever animosity that you
built up during that period of time of
whatever you know uh vitriol you were
getting as a as a child because we all
got it if we had a Game Boy in our
pockets
right because you're supposed to be
outside doing bad things and playing
with women well playing with girls if
you're not doing that and you're playing
video games something's wrong with you
and that's what we just looked at you
took us out of that
So for anybody to to to Champion your
demise off of
um off a boss key or something a game or
something that you didn't perform well I
think that's bad on them because
I really appreciate that
um for me it was like when I was coming
up and looking at like you know
mentioning earlier you know Carmack and
Romero right you know we all remember
the the debacle of when he had his own
studio with ion store yeah yeah Katana
yeah Katana and we were like I was even
myself I was like I wanted to see that
guy fail and like in hindsight years
later you know ramire and I you know we
became friends and you know I I asked
him one time I was like so what was the
whole deal there he's like he's just
like I just wanted to make a cool place
for people to make cool games you know
that's that's all I wanted to do you
know and years later he's still doing
his thing and he's still thriving you
know he's happily married to Brenda
who's also a video game Legend and it
just it's so funny for me also to to to
take my wife around to these video game
events and introduce her to some of
these video game Legends I've known for
decades she actually worked at ID
software she worked with Carmack Carmack
would handle like the iPhone version of
Doom B like give me some feedback on
that I'm like you worked with Carmack
like
[Laughter]
she like didn't even know but it's one
of those things like you know it's the
whole shot and fraud and you know I
compare it to it's the whole it's like
Britney Spears right like you know
everyone loves Brittany right and the
thing is is Brittany you know have that
that face in about 2007 where she kind
of maybe went a little bit yeah right uh
there was a conservatorship
her Instagram is still kind of weird
um yeah that was crazy the thing is you
know she was born to be a performer
right and for me like that drama nerd me
you know I need the stage that's why you
know going back to the karaoke thing and
going back to you know I could you know
doing a a keynote and things like that
like I I love for it it's like Lady Gaga
says I live through the Applause so is
that you micro Dolson uh weekly to get
your fix of the crowd of that the
adulation well the kicker is is um we do
it so there's a few spots in town that
do do karaoke right right karaoke is
such an art form like I have a whole
screenplay I want to write called mic
droppers about a guy who's a software
engineer and his Studios failing and
then eventually finds his way through
karaoke but we do it at the I co-owned
the Raleigh beer garden in town and
every Monday night at eight o'clock you
know we get a really really good crowd
and I'm sitting here thinking these
people are all buying beer and buying
pretzels to to see me sing you know
and then again you gotta you gotta read
the crowd because inevitably you have to
go to Mr Brightside yeah no doubt I want
to get addicted man real quick um about
about gears you know or maybe just any
questions specifically that we made Mr
during this uh
history I I do have a question about
gears you know modern gears uh I'm have
you played the monitors because I know
like I don't know I remember Jeffy said
you know it took him a long time before
he plunged and played you know the the
modern God of Wars have you played the
modern gears and if so you know uh
what's your input on the direction that
the studios went with it I played four
and I beat it and I enjoyed it um I
played five for a bit but I had issues
the the controls felt weird to me okay
um there's so much little stuff behind
the scenes that goes into making a good
shooter work on a console you know the
whole idea of you know slowing the
cursor as it moves over an enemy uh how
much the bullets auto aim on to uh foes
and one on things like that it just felt
kind of off but the thing is they did
that whole decision thing in years
you figure out like who lives and who
dies and I think it was one of the
dumbest things they could have ever done
Canon wise is that your concern I just
you know like when Dom died everyone
felt it yeah like and it was one of
those things you know like we were so
criticized back in the day for the
dialogue of gears and it's just so big
stupid dude
and once in a while you know I'm sitting
there in the afternoon maybe I'll have a
mimosa and I'll go to YouTube and look
up those videos and every single comment
is like tears tears tears
as I was playing this with my best
friend and then Dom died and I just
couldn't recover for like four days yeah
you know what it is people like to
criticize things that come off as corny
but we're human beings we love corny
like we love corny we love all of that
the hero story The Ark the the sacrifice
we love all of that and I won't give you
know Cliffy and a team your credit in a
sense that for me what I really miss
about gears was more of like the horror
aspect and and being scared actually
that was actually one of Phil Spencer's
main notes when they acquired the IP
that he wanted he gave the marching
orders for Rod was they left out you
know kind of the horror the thing is is
this something happened also with the
Dead Space franchise where you know Dead
Space one and two were great you know
survival horror games and then they just
doubled down in the action aspect and
all this comes down to pacing right like
you know you can if you have those scary
moments you have to build up to it I
mean you're talking to the guy who did
the intro for the scar and the first
unreal yeah
and the door opens and things like that
and that's one of the things I learned
you know even when I I was you know on
the road with Mark rain back in the day
demoing the Unreal Engine you know you
can feel when you start losing the room
you know that's one of my things you
know next up I think I want to actually
try doing stand-up comedy and going to
you know like Open Mic nights and seeing
what I can pull off and because that in
itself is also an art form you know the
Arts all of it right we actually just
had a comedian online
I have almost 700 people
like what rare animal we save when we
get we hit the like well today we saving
the Platypus the Dominican Planet
every time you hit the like that's what
happens oh a lamb Ben will will be saved
today yeah will not get chainsaw today
going back going back to gears gears was
developed during one of the hardest
periods of my adult life right you know
I've always been a late bloomer you know
I was like 30 years old and I was still
emotional only 15 because if you recall
in the book you know that was a very
similar year for me with a bunch of
horrible things that happened to you and
so you know just a big case of Arrested
Development and that's the thing is you
know like I I remember getting a card
for my wife one year and it says don't
grow up it's a trap
[Laughter]
stay young at heart and you know I don't
want I don't want kids but one of the
things I've gleaned from people who have
kids is you get to kind of relive your
childhood through their eyes you know
it's like looking at my brother who just
has two wonderful children and like for
him to introduce his son and daughter to
you know the world of Transformers you
know praise all along and that's that's
what I call a forever IP by the way like
once once it once it transitions it to a
new generation yeah that's that's when
it becomes the thing and like you know
we're going to be hearing about Pokemon
for the next 5 000 years oh yeah oh what
are your thoughts on uh Michael Bay
Transformers oh God
be careful I'm not allowed to curse in
this podcast thank you thank you good
answer
that's what I'm talking about the
Bumblebee movie was great no yes that
was callbacks to G1 and sensibilities so
I I respected it when my when you're
when your character designs look like a
bunch of shaved metal pieces together I
mean that's one of the the greatest
things about generation one especially a
Transformers is where you can kind of
tell what the robot would turn into
right like right you know and that's you
know Optimus Prime you know this big
barrel chest that was the truck and
things like that because Transformers
started off as diet clone in Japan yes
yeah and then Hasbro took it and they
gave it like an IP the heroic Autobots
and the evil Decepticons and Cybertron
and everything like that and as a
generation of kids we were just hooked
and so much of that was an influence
like that GI Joe thunderstorm let's go
that that was all like for everything
that I've done in my entire life that's
the thing is you know what I'm working
on right now is a new world with that
has a dog that's a superhero because as
far as I'm concerned I've never seen a
cool tough dog superhero that's been
depicted is that because I lost my my
best friend uh sir Benjamin Johnson so
when I was reading something okay and
and you lost your dog I'm like oh man
that's my teddy Shrine right there
I have the ashes I have the paw print I
have the picture I have all that stuff
upstairs uh I have a painting of him
um
people don't understand like that hits
hard right really honestly the thing the
thing the internet thought it was so
freaking hilarious that like I started
my studio and I'm this cocky celebrity
game designer and like you know I
employed 80 of my friends yeah for three
three and a half years I knew their
spouses I knew their children I knew
their pets and they brought their they
brought their dogs to the office right
and then within a similar time frame I
had to put down my Aussie of 13 years
because he couldn't walk anymore you
know and it just destroyed me and then
you know my I know you're supposed to
adopt not shop I know but my wife my
wife found this Pomsky named lady and I
felt I fell in love immediately with her
and she's just such a beautiful just a
lewd floof and she's been my inspiration
and like that's the thing about
creativity as you all I'll obviously
know is you know who's your Muse is it
could be an animal it could be a
location it could be a person right and
sometimes it comes out of Sorrow you
know gears was birthed out of the fail
of my first marriage right oh so
is
base uh Loosely around your father yeah
a little bit Yeah but also Anya
eventually evolved into Lauren um and
that's the thing is you know during
crunch time oh here's lady uh you guys
want to see her I can't get it from that
end
oh there we go there we go she's like
it's too early
that one was already in the shot she's
down at the bottom yeah all right so
yeah the whole thing is just during the
you know because the crunch time is
still a thing in game development right
right unfortunately and it sucks but
it's it's kind of the reality because
Gamers expect so much out of a game you
know the features set the graphics
everything like that and so you know my
wife and I we bought a place at the
Carolina Shore and that was my escape on
the weekends during crunch time and
that's why Gears of War 3 ends with
Marcus and Anya sitting on the beach and
you know the idea of this this pristine
Beach location that's been kept away
from the proletariat workers and and the
the poor people you know was was very
much an idea I wanted to make sure it
was in Gears uh three and so when you
know Anya turns to Marcus and says we
have it tomorrow I think that was one of
the best narrative decisions they made
was to give Marcus and Anya's son you
know and then to continue the lineage
because Lord knows I don't freaking want
one
um did you get any of these Community
questions no I'm gonna get it I got one
more before we get I know I got one or
two more before we get to the community
I did want to ask
um during the 360 era of gears and I
know you spoke one very highly of Rod
right and salute to The Legend
um I wanted to ask about peterbor
in that era like you know how was it
interacting with him during that era you
know obviously 360s trying to come on
the scene establish itself and then also
you know were you part of the decision
because gears were so vital for 360 were
you part of that decision for like what
is it the 5 12 Ram uh decision as far as
what gears could look like yeah so yeah
the whole like uh you know adding extra
memory to the Xbox 360. that was uh Mark
rain and Tim Sweeney basically put their
foot down okay at the time it was Shane
Kim that was actually the one who's
responsible were those decisions but
Peter Moore is an absolute gentleman and
a scholar he is an absolute I I can't
say that word but he's just a bad MF
he he's the kind of guy that can just I
don't know if it's the British accent or
not that's that Liverpool that's that
Liverpool
there's a charm there's a charm and it's
like the thing about having an accent
like that is you can't tell if the
person is intelligent or not
interested development where she turned
out she was really dumb but she slashing
smart because she had an accent right
but Peter's brilliant um he's pure
Charisma and that's the thing about
doing these these press junkets you know
these these conferences like so many
people that they put on stage are
terrible at it and he's a Shulman bro I
mean he's Hugh Jackman of the greatest
showman you know yes ladies and gents
this is the moment you've waited for
right
you see so many of these guys guys women
whatever on stage right and they do this
thing like you tell here's prompter one
prompter two and they go
it's great to be here
we're here with Xbox
we got some great games to show you and
you can just feel the collective like
like audience is like okay let's keep it
going you know like let's cut to the
exclusive and again that comes back to
pacing so much of life is systems and
pacing you know like the thing about you
know we were talking earlier about
Marvel and DC and comic book movies like
one of my favorite things to do is to go
to YouTube and look up
um the videos from endgame right and you
know when uh you know Tony Stark says
you know I am Iron Man and they just I'm
getting chills you can see and I'm not
even that huge of a Marvel Fanboy but
like you know it's the same thing with
musicals right like it when you know
getting into Broadway and being a
Broadway producer and you know talking
to one of my producing Partners Kayla
from TBD Productions and she's like well
you seem pretty good at what you're
doing with this and I'm like you can't
fake the Goosebumps yeah right and like
when the music hits that Crescendo it's
the same thing with a good concert it's
the same thing with a good video game
it's the same thing with a good dining
experience the same thing with you know
being in a good relationship pacing in
In Cadence it's all of it it's
everything same thing with stand up you
know it's all systems and I'm pretty
much freaking all over the board these
days if you haven't figured it out
you're micro dosing all around this is
what I'm noticing because like you were
at the Apex so that level of ovulation
is not going to be uh supplanted by
something small like karaoke here but
you will still get those knots when
you're about to do the song and you
still fill in the room yeah I think
you're still
in that that moment that Shining Moment
around all the things that you do from
Broadway even my new therapist please
no well I mean once you said that you
went to therapy because your father died
and stuff like that I'm like I'm really
reading the book I'm really
understanding you more because before
then I didn't right before then you were
just Alpha and Omega to me right you you
came from the bottom and you raised to
the top you were at this point with
Nintendo because it seems like I knew
you but I didn't know you in the book
control free allows me to get to know
the person The Humble person the person
that found that Medium right because you
were here to me with the Lamborghini and
you were also here to me with the Super
Mario stuff
um I mean well Mario Brothers I'm just
saying now you're out of space but
you're still craved that you know for me
boxing
and fighting people and hearing a crowd
outside the ring you never walk away
from that you always feel that and I'm
seeing you get that little fuel from all
the Endeavors that you're doing now yeah
it's fantastic I think I think that's
really honestly really really
appreciated I really appreciate that
yeah I think what I got from the book
was was the fact that all the stuff that
you mentioned came is back then it felt
like Cliff like like you needed it yeah
in turn because that's how you were kind
of drowning the the sorrows and the
things that were going wrong in your
life and kind of just enveloping
yourself in other things and sort of
drowning that out and not addressing it
and now you have the hindsight of time
and and just distance from it and it's
like now and wisdom exactly and it's and
it's you kind of can process it and and
take everything that you need to from it
and learn from it and and you're just is
a place where you enjoy it and you know
you can do it and you're good at it but
you don't need it anymore you want to
get to the point where you feel like
your life is an RPG in the world is
finally open to you
exactly I mean without the weapon
degradation
let's get this guy off the show
that's the funny thing about like
somehow I've managed to amass this
really interesting network of people
like and just you know so basically um
at San Diego Comic-Con for a few years
um Justin broiling from Ricky Morty Yes
again that's uh
he's a good friend of mine but we're not
gonna go there absolutely um and Alex
Hirsch from Gravity Falls we would throw
uh what we call the big dummy yacht
party and um you know it wasn't cheap
but we basically wind up like with the
most random people there like you know
like the cast of Game of Thrones rolls
up and then you know like uh you know
nipple Twisters
Kiki wolf kill from 343 a lot of Pierce
right like yeah and then you know like
Riley Reed shows up at one point and and
Weird Al Yankovic and wow Lin Manuel
Miranda shows up and like I'm saying
this is the craziest craziest group wow
Kelly Ripa and Mark Miss Willows and
stuff and I was like what I'm getting
drunk with all these people what is
going on right now and Riley reads
flashing her who hot everyone
you've all seen it Riley okay
every time every time I see her videos
I'm like
yeah that tattoo will make it really
hurt
that was the kicker about meeting her at
the at that party by the way is like she
comes up and she's like my name is
so-and-so be you might know me about the
stage name Riley Reid and I shake her
hand and if you ever meet somebody who's
involved in adult stuff every filthy
thing you've ever seen them
and then Lauren turns to me and she goes
how do you know her oh okay
yes I just I just like I like knowing
interesting people like so you know
doing the whole karaoke thing every
Monday at our beer garden
um there's this woman that rolled up
named Jade and she can sing like
nobody's business she does that whole
bit in Phantom where it's like
oh wow and the entire bar just stops and
just watches her when she does it and
she's actually having a burlesque show
she's in downtown Raleigh tonight so we
like became friends through that and
like I just I just I just love meeting
interesting and cool people you know
people who just do something cool like
you know if you if you ever had a bar
and you're like run into somebody that
was like a doctor like an ER nurse or
something like that like they have some
stories you know yeah usually about
people accidentally wanting stuff in
their butts
[Laughter]
before hamsters
life has taught me you know is that it's
too freaking short yeah
my dad my dad just boom you know and
then what happened it's my mother-in-law
a couple years ago was diagnosed with
stage four lung cancer never smoked a
day in her life is during the era of
coven we had to go back and forth
non-stop to the suburbs of Louisiana
um and basically watch her Decline and
which really messed me up and then just
really realizing that you know I'm I'm a
huge fan of Patton Oswald the comedian
right
um and he did that whole bit remember he
lost his wife Michelle McNamara yeah
um and she was on some medications had
pneumonia he woke up one day and she was
just gone next to him and you know he
said the hardest day of his life wasn't
the day when his wife died it was the
next day where he had to take his
daughter to the playground and tell her
what happened and he said the words of
wisdom that he got from his wife
Michelle was about life it's chaos be
kind right and you know and you know
when when Lauren and I get into like
little fights it's like Life's Too Short
dude you know that's the thing it goes
back to that Shia LaBeouf video right it
was like just do it just like just do it
just do it yeah exactly real talk real
talk about it very very important words
of wisdom there I mean still one more
question for you but I know we got to
get the community in the bar so I did
want to ask one part about
the transitioning from Epic and you know
how it went down with Tim Sweeney and
Mark and then the other the second part
of my last question was kind of like you
know
them selling to our gears to Microsoft
and you spoke highly of Phil in
reference to that portrait so I wanted
to get that first part about you know
the the what's called with Tim and Mark
and then moving on and then obviously
themseling gears and your comments about
Phil yeah well the thing about Mark
Raine is he's always been transparent
that he loves the thrill of the Chase
and he loves making money you know I
mean we live in a capitalist society and
he's pretty unabashedly a capitalist
um the thing was is you know Tim and
Mark were kind of father figures to me
for years you know when I started
working with them I was I was a baby
and what they took very very good care
of me and then you know the the 10 cent
investment hit epic and I realized I
know a lot I no longer had to argue with
programmers anymore about my ideas
I remember sitting there with a program
and I'm like I want to see these
creatures I'm gonna call them the Locust
and they're going to be from the
underground on the planet and
programmers like I don't buy it I'm like
what what don't you buy it's like how'd
they get there I'm like that's part of
the mystery
but then that's the thing is you know
like I escaped you know out to my little
beach spot you know those years ago and
Tim Sweeney actually drove down uh and
and you know he and I went for a walk in
the beach and it reminded me of that
final scene from the movie contact where
Jody Foster you know first encounters
the alien and it winds up taking form of
her father and Tim was very much a
father figure to me and you know he's
the kind of guy that you know he's got
so much money now and he's doing it to
buy land in North Carolina for for like
land conservation he's doing really
really great work in that department but
the thing is is um you know I I missed
my time at Epic I'll always appreciate
it but you know I've moved on but what
was the second half of the question the
second half was now they sell gears to
Microsoft okay so that was the thing is
that that's one of the things that that
missed me a little bit is the fact that
you know Tim and Mark didn't let me know
you know I actually got a phone call and
so Phil lets you know he'll let you know
he's a stand-up dude every time I've
I've met him and talked to him or
whatever I've just he just comes across
as a stand-up guy he really is and
that's that's the thing is you know I
have this phrase I've been using lately
I have a lot of phrases
um establishing character shot right
like and you know when someone shows you
who they are believe them this goes back
to Peter Moore goes back to Phil Spencer
you know they're they're just stand-up
dudes you know Tim and Mark are as well
right and you know there's the saying
about Hollywood it's not show friends
it's show business but in many ways it
is show Friends there's a reason why you
know Steven Spielberg has worked with
Tom Hanks so much you know you know
filming a TV show or a movie it's a lot
of work and you're on set for for many
many hours you know so you want to be
around people that are you know you you
kind of vibe with right right but you
know in regards to the future you know
I'm working with um Alex decampy um she
did a many graphic novels she did one
with Duncan Jones Duncan Jones directed
The World of Warcraft movie uh source
code and moon and you know we're working
on that dog project together and there's
other things that are you know in the
queue but I just I love engaging with
the creative and that's the thing is
like at Bosque when I started the studio
like I felt like I was in charge I felt
like I had creative control over the
project and then I just gave the team
their ability to do what they felt was
right and we wound up with a really good
game but it wasn't in my heart hearts
the kind of game I originally really
wanted to make yeah and so you know you
live and learn you know it's uh you know
even Will Smith had Wild Wild West yeah
I think he turned down the Matrix I
think yeah thank God thank God he did
yeah yeah it's funny we do have to see
Salma Hayek spot though
I actually sent a king uh it was a video
that of him talking about that he's like
look man if you guys you know if
anything you guys got to thank me he's
like because if I would have accepted
that row they're gonna make Morpheus
white and he's like that
thank God he did that he was like in the
long term things I say The Matrix okay
so as Spike Lee says we always have to
have the magical negro right
[Laughter]
also you get you get a phone call you
know that they are uh selling to
Microsoft and I didn't get a dime off of
it wow yeah so so is it um what's the
thought process there because this this
is pretty much you know your Collective
baby
um so we can take the money and just put
that over here right right here put it
to the side just yeah go about the film
I just don't mess it up was all I wanted
right I think the Coalition has done a
good job you know I just I feel like
there's a little bit of that je ne sais
quoi that little Special Sauce that just
kind of been missing the last couple and
I've been I've been very very obvious
and open about the fact that I'd be
happy to that's about to say if they
brought it awesome is it the part that
you feel that is out of it because I
felt in the first three
had that horror but also had heart right
what do you think is missing
I don't know you know honestly maybe me
what's up the thing is this this goes
back to um again this is another person
in Hollywood who's had a rough patch as
of late Josh Wheaton right yes right
um I'm a huge Buffy fan yeah I just you
know my wife looks just like Sarah
Michelle Geller because I had the
biggest crush on her for so long and
then I'm like okay this is all making
sense now
you know what I was I was talking to
Joss at one Comic-Con one time and he
said to me you know we've learned you
know years into making Buffy you know
Buffy suffer show good you know and
Gears of War was made in the wake of the
George Bush administration's you know
stupid Wars you know right and you know
he had Iraq and Afghanistan and all that
going on and it was very much a
criticism of the American
military-industrial complex right so
many people didn't get it's like you
know the game opens with oil pumps
people like yeah right hello
um and they're like no way and Sarah is
Aries spelled backwards oh my God
I'm like
um but yeah it was one of those things I
think
I think game developers and creatives in
general should make their work personal
right and that's the thing is you know
gears was incredibly personal you know
for me coming out of you know the failed
marriage and you know making I made the
Berserker the only female the Locust
right like that what kind of messed up
massages
the Unstoppable field and that was true
fear in that room when you yeah
like yeah she I think she killed me like
four times before I'm watching The Last
of Us and enjoying it and then the
bloater comes out I'm like ah okay yeah
you know one thing I want to give you a
promise before you continue is um shout
out to you for the crew or whoever was
helped you with the Krill because I feel
like that that fear of going from the
light oh yeah you gotta be safe be
careful like I just missed that little
aspect of it but continue so it was
inspired by pitch black obviously
I mean you know everything is a remix
that's the thing is you know whenever
you consume a movie TV show comic book
it's all Christ for the creative Mill
yeah I read a book called hitmakers that
basically says you know the key to
success is to have something that feels
familiar but different right and that's
the thing you know the new season of
Mandalorian is about to drop oh yeah
it's a freaking Western yeah you know
that that that's that's what Firefly was
you know and that's the thing is you
know Star Wars was Hidden Fortress kind
of redone in sci-fi yeah and you know
Gears of War was you know that game kill
switch meets Resident Evil 4. right so
take something you know like the dog
thing I'm working on it's like you know
I want to very much tap into that
generation of kids that love Paw Patrol
but what happens when Paw Patrol is no
longer cool right and they start they
suddenly start turning 10 11 12 and they
want something that's kind of PG-13 with
a dog that can really mess stuff up
right
hopefully that drops in July but
okay yeah well you heard that here you
heard that here
can I ask one last selfish question
this interview's done
I'm a Broadway boy as well I I love that
stuff it really I just ever since I saw
Phantom of the Opera I was hooked that
was that was my gateway drug too so tell
me like now you know Tony award-winning
you know producer Hades of hadesinski
um when they said they were shutting
down was there anything from you like
I'm Cliff blazinski I'm gonna try to
save Phantom of the Opera was there any
thoughts
it all comes down to money yeah and
that's the thing I think Phantom had
like a 30-year run at this point right
I'm you know we're actually we're up
there in April we're actually gonna go
see it right before right before it
closes and they know it they're gonna
they gouge Us in the ticket prices no
but the thing about like I love like
live life performances like the thing is
just like before coven you know at the
end of Hades town you know they they
there's a line where they say we raise
our glasses and toast to Orpheus you
know because maybe this the story will
turn out different next time and there
actually would cheers people in the
front row right and there's you know the
moment where you know Orpheus is you
know following uh eurydice out of uh
Hades hell and you know he turns around
you know like and basically like you
know she gets doomed to Hell forever and
you know a woman in the front row is
just losing it and Andre Andre de
Shields the Broadway Legend who played
Hermes for a while like took out his
handkerchief and headed it to her and
these are those moments that you can't
get you can't with streaming or anything
like that and then you know for me to
infiltrate that world and to be able to
like go backstage and then also to see
the how things are capitalized in the
imaginations of how Broadway is made
it's not that different than video games
to be honest but I just have a
tremendous amount of respect for anybody
involved with that
um it's just you know they have to be on
for two and a half hours you know eight
times a week yeah it's just the the just
the vibe of going to a show and and
getting hooked on one you know the Mean
Girls musical dear Evan Hansen like come
from away all of it I just I I believe
it's uh it's a universal kind of thing
to kind of unite people but the thing is
is some people just can't get into
musicals they can't buy the fact that
they can't suspend their disbelief the
fact that these people are just going to
start singing Just Go With It exactly I
was the first time the chandelier the
first time I went I sat in the very last
row was a school trip I didn't want to
go because my sixth grade teacher had I
just messed up my mind because she
forced opera on us
um so I heard Phantom of the Opera I'm
just like it's Opera I don't want to go
and the moment the chandelier comes on
and I feel the heat from the chandelier
and you're here
I was like what is this that's it I was
hooked and I and I never looked back and
it is that thing that you mentioned
about how it's just every single
performance is its own little thing that
is going to be lost the time because
it's your it's your personal memory I
have such a soft spot not only for game
developers but also for theater nerds
yeah you know to infiltrate that world
and become friends with them like the
the types of people that that perform
these shows and they're so good at what
they do and like they're just they're
actually someone underpaid but it's uh
it's just such an amazing art form and I
just uh there there's actually going to
be a big announcement in a couple months
of one that I'm involved with what's
coming up okay I told you he has his
hand in the whole body because that's
because he fuels that adulation I'm
telling you it's it's therapist King
yeah no because if if you really just
listen and pay attention to to what he's
doing it's you can't come from the Apex
and just be medium it's just not gonna
happen and he was the apex predator he
was the big gorilla in the room like
Cliff walks in a room you're like that's
the guy that's it quick uh we got to get
the community question before we wrap
yeah and we've got to respect uh Lord
Eclipse time um so quick question from
the community they said what was the
goal as far as far as decision to make
gear is a cover based shooter and they
say I say this because giz has a very
unique gameplay style that seemed very
risky at the time
yeah I mean it was basically uh you know
I love games that fail because you can
see what they try to do and then take it
from there and make it better and that
was you know when Lee Perry showed me
kill switch and I was like yeah there's
something so compelling about the
character like actually interacting with
the world yeah right and then you know
Perfect Dark came out uh I think it was
perfect dark zero and you could take
cover in like four spots yeah and I was
like no let's make this like a universal
thing and let's you know let's combine
it with the rolling let's combining it
with everything and the thing is is we
had the graphical Advantage
when you have that graphical Advantage
you can take the player's controls and
say hey no here's how are you going to
play now you're not just gonna run
around like an idiot you know you're
actually gonna have to take cover and of
course they all want to rolling around
here
all right but that's that's the thing is
you know there there's very much this
kind of like directorial like back and
forth that happens with the game and
design that you make as a creative with
you know the players and you're kind of
teaching them you're actually yeah in a
lot of ways being a teacher to the
player and uh you know it was a great
time it was the best sometimes it was
the worst of times I think the cover
based thing when you made them have
gravitas because
Marcus slams up against a piece of
concrete it's like like he Rodeo run
into it and you Slam against it it feels
very visceral it gives you that that
real world tension that's all that's
just feedback in general that's just
good game design it's the same thing you
know the term of gun feel you know right
you play the new Call of Duty against
the gun feel right just to feel crisp
just a Reload pop right right you know
actually you guys fall like I Commander
Carl on social he does those like
reloads like reloads like you know
ketchup packets and stuff
trust me it's great but yeah I mean
that's one of the things like so to to
nitpick one of the newer gears so I was
watching uh my wife play horde in uh
gears five and the camera like when
when you play a gears game the main
character and you zoom in should be the
bottom left of the screen and like I'm
watching her play as Anya and like it's
the entire left side of the screen and
I'm like no this is the kind of stuff
that I would fix I do right I go to
multi-city European press tour and I
come back and let the camera be all
messed up the blood would just be like
hosed and I'm like no one noticed this
it's just a little kid you see it's the
little that's why I told you I'm just
like
it's just job insurance but also that's
the thing is learning all these systems
the same thing about learning how film
works and you know like I'll turn to
Lauren like during a movie I'm like that
was a really great shot did you check
that was actually one take and she's
like oh yeah it really was all right the
music kicks in or you know somebody's
line delivery and that's going back to
the whole Marvel and DC thing by the way
if your entire movie trailer is just CG
stuff I don't want to see your movie not
at all my my favorite movie my favorite
uh Marvel moment was you know Tony Stark
um sitting there with cap and they're at
the cabin right oh yeah they're chopping
wood this is during an age yeah
you can see see Civil War kind of brute
breaks the you know to remind you he's a
superhero but no CG no outfits nothing
just two people having differentiating
ideologies you know and you don't other
so when the big you know act three CG
stuff happens then you actually care
right as opposed to you know so much of
it these days just like throw CG out of
and you know everybody in China will go
and watch it
that's a community question was uh Cliff
would you ever work for Xbox and create
a small team similar to a team that made
Hi-Fi Rush
I mean I'm open to anything at this
point the thing is you know this is
another one of those other phrases that
I learned is don't sit at a table that
you can't walk away from right and so
that's the thing about me being I'm
financially independent you know and I I
have full creative control over the
multiple IPS that I'm working on right
and if somebody wants to come and you
know fund it and do some stuff I'm I'm
all ears honestly nah bro man trebelius
journey I mean man this we could go on
with you for hours but this this is
amazing you know a true honor one thing
I respect about you is just your brutal
honesty with a little bit of the
self-deprecate you but you always come
full circle and I love the passion that
you put in your projects you know the
personalization the heart you know
obviously you've been through a lot you
don't say with your dad listen I highly
advise people please please read this
book one more time exactly control freak
brother you know a couple things that
welt me up you know as far as the the
kid alluded to the the bullying and and
the the the abusive situation really
really hit hard and um for me personally
I guess my personal final question is uh
you know why put yourself out there like
that why you know this is really Vivid
stuff that a lot of people would never
share as men we don't share that
generally so I wouldn't commend you on
that but why what motivated you to put
that out there it was therapy it was
basically therapy that I make a little
bit of money off of honestly but I
believe you know like the thing you know
the elephant of the room is you know me
talking about the fact that I was
molested when by a guy that invented the
Internet when I was 15. these are things
that we as dudes don't talk about right
and this this is the kind of you know
we're talking about Boston earlier right
and there's a certain type of dude who
goes out to a bar right and if he's not
gonna get a hook up for the night he's
picking a fight yeah and half the time
he winds up sitting on the curb crying
because you know his dad didn't love him
enough or you know whatever happened
right and that's the thing is you know
we as dudes you know we have to be in
touch with our feelings you know like
and that's the funniest thing about my
Louisiana needs right like you know like
you know when I watch something
entertaining with her and I get a little
misty-eyed she thinks it's hilarious
that I actually cry at like an
entertaining movie like and I'm like and
for me I'm like as you know a male
figure in her life for her to see that I
actually have feelings I think is
healthy yes very healthy and you know I
think that's just incredibly important
for dudes in general and I think you
know if we we start going down the the
flow chart of why we have so many mass
shootings in America I think that's one
of the very many variables that are
leading to this kind of thing you know
and also you know an entire Young
Generation of men that have no idea how
to communicate yes yeah you know when
you live online 24 7 you have no idea
how to make eye contact
UM
it really is if you live on eight chain
and 4chan 24 20 years existence is memes
right and you know it's just it's it's
it's it's it's messed up out there you
know and I just for me as someone who's
gone through the losses that I've had
that the highs and the lows if I can
share it with somebody out there and
hopefully inspire a new generation of
people then you know maybe I'm doing
is there audio versus the audio version
I'm like look I I agree with you guys
man I like what people I've listened to
it twice like yeah listen to it while
you're driving people Mark rain actually
gave me crap he's like you should be
doing the audiobook yourself and I'm
like I can't because every time I get to
certain parts of the book I get way too
choked up yeah it's it's essentially
it's a love story of my love of video
games but also video games leading to
the love of my life with my wife right
but through also you know losing my
father my nephew and everything that I
I'd gone through and then just figuring
out what's next yeah and uh but stay
tuned in the next few months there's
gonna be some more news put the links to
the book of the chat y'all go get that
for real man it's extremely personal
extremely dope the the tradition that we
do before we get people out of there I
just put the Audio I got you the liver
exits in there control foot look at the
Lakers in there boom where's the book
come on come on get it I got you with
the links in It Go Get It Go cop they
got the audio and all that um we do the
tradition we ask uh every guess before
we get the body here we need Lord Cliffs
top five video games or franchises of
all time and your favorite console of
all time and why
uh Playstation Two because it was just
such a golden era of gaming for the
console
E3 in in in Playing God of War
um and just being like wow that was just
amazing PlayStation one was terrible I'm
sorry
I'm about to kick you off the shoulders
I mean come on
fidelity
playing battle arena to Shannon okay
well yeah Virtual Fighter was better
Tetris is goat
um Street Fighter 2 okay
um the Halo franchise okay
Counter-Strike and then uh Resident Evil
4.
that you didn't pick anything of yours
but this is this is you every time I
dissect this onion it gets a little more
deeper thank you hopefully the onion
doesn't make you cry
salute to the legendary cliff lizisky in
the realm and absolute present brother
we gave you talk video games all day you
are a Legend You're an icon one of the
last rock stars of the industry Brothers
right still looking good you know what
I'm saying that's right salute soft
addict let's give them all outros get
about good man anything you want to say
to the legend before he heads back to
his date yeah I definitely appreciate
you coming on because I remember I was
talking to Cog and uh we were we were
actually in the process of setting up
the Hi-Fi Rush interview and I was like
you know what I'm gonna go on Twitter
and just shoot our shot for Cliffy B
shout out to Adam he's like he's like I
mean yeah man go ahead and try and then
and then like 30 minutes later you you
respond I'm like yo we know what to do
ha because you was always like one of
the the you know the on The Bucket List
you know I got these filthy on the slow
Wayne Gretzky thing you miss 100 of the
shots
pitted me of that bro we would not be
where we are if it was a fat the way he
shoots his shot so thank you but I gotta
say that to you live people he's very
critical to the success of IOP and
that's my Pro Solutions
well thank you for having me guys I
really appreciate it
yeah I got them yeah uh listen Cliff I I
listened to your book as soon as it came
out and I listened to it again this past
week to get ready for the show and both
times uh for me it was just drawing the
parallels between your life and mine and
in terms of like just the bullying and
kind of feeling like I don't belong and
then just sort of coming into my own and
then sort of letting it go to my head
and then losing myself a little bit and
then bring being brought down to Earth
by just making bad decisions based on
that hubris and sort of where that took
me and I think one of the big things
having a starter marriage just like you
did as well and just and learning a lot
about myself and growing up
um
yeah I remember that first marriage I
remember that first marriage but I I am
not who I am today without that
happening so to see your journey and to
see where you where you come to and it
for me a lot of my happiness today comes
from the fact that I did find my forever
person after that and it could not have
been without the struggles that I went
through so just drawing those parallels
between what what you've done and what
I've done and experienced it just it
just kind of made me have a a whole new
level of respect for you so again thank
you uh I'm just so happy for your
journey I'm I'm excited to see what else
you do
um but man thanks for coming on man I
really appreciate it no doubt thanks for
having me king boss for the legend
before he leaves okay so
um first I want to like to say thank you
second I never thought in a million
years I would be in this position to
talk to somebody that I've idolized for
a very long period of time
um so my wife got a chance to see me do
research really really do I do research
that is true on on the people I'm like
yeah okay we got that person this week
and it's whatever
shout out to all the games
no well it's not that it's just the fact
that I I hold him in a supreme reverence
I really do it's very few people that I
do hold in this space and and you're
definitely one of them but she got a
chance to see me do research you see me
well she watched me and listen to me
listen to the book right and it was just
points where I thought I knew you and
I'm getting to know you yeah right so I
got to know I I knew Cliffy B
I didn't know Clifford right and I got a
chance to learn and know Clifford
so that's why when I addressed you and
and when I put out the promo it was
Clifford belinski all right because you
grew into that space you grew from the
the child and you had to build a shield
around yourself which was Cliffy B and
Cliffy B took you to the heights but it
also took you to the dock and you came
down to Clifford and you're in this
happy medium you have you know Wonderful
uh person that you want to end time with
you know um you're in a happy place
you're in a great place and you're micro
dosing and getting your adulation from
all around and you're still working and
creating right um you're going to turn
into your Galvatron right Megatron yeah
yeah you know you're not done yet so
you're going to turn into your Galvatron
new body you know and maybe maybe you
you are the Decepticon not the owner
right Daddy's Autobot but he actually
just went there
but arise no one
um because when you when you when you
lost the company you know and I lost and
I lost two companies and you know like
you said feeding the people and seeing
the people and stuff like that that hurt
I was ignorant thinking oh he went with
the PlayStation
which was a mistake okay can you explain
that to kick real quick I know I'm
asking for too much on your time but
because King was hurt no I was really
hurt because I was like that's disease
they had the bigger bigger install base
at the time obviously yeah business
business it was just business exactly
and I respect it
but I also love the the the journey in
the person and I can't wait to see the
stuff that you're gonna do so it's just
it meant so much that I was I was early
they called me I was up early I was
watching the priest I was doing
everything yeah I saw another chat I was
like what is this
2012 30 doesn't seem early but the king
that's that's early
it's early for me too so I'm
with this opportunity that you've given
us and then you've put a foot note in in
my little history right now so when I
show this to my kids and you didn't
curse like and when I show this to my
children my children
he did he only did one curse oh no he
did he beat you yeah
it was like all right I'm done
both of my sons can watch this and and
say that hey Daddy did this to me daddy
met his his Idol you lived up to every
expectation thank you sir I appreciate
you thank you so much how much per hour
for therapy
the legend enjoy your day brother thank
you so much you're welcome into Eddie
Tom again the legendary Lord Clifford
blazinski the rockstar
thank you so much
no doubt so if you want to get the super
chats yes sir hold on a second oh we got
some spicy over here yeah yeah
that wasn't even for me it's just it's
just like Wow Wow for real for real all
right let's go back to the beginning
should I do the ball okay
uh I think you're going to do the poll
question why you're doing that I think
the only other person that like I would
really love to have on the industry
besides obviously like Phil Spencer
besides Cliff well it's like Todd Howard
like yeah
I got um I got Reggie yeah Reggie yeah
Reggie bill yeah Phil I don't think
we'll ever have my own model
in the people that spoken with the
overall success of the Nintendo switch
third best selling console of all time
but recent declining numbers in last
quarter what do you think is the right
decision for Nintendo regarding their
current hallway the winner of the
four-way ILP poll at 58 of the vote was
next gen Nintendo console group oh wait
what the next thing what a full on new
start new hardware coming in second
place at 21 of the vote was switch pro
upgrade
and then first time in a while last
place was tied so it's keeping status
quo that the switch is fine
and I don't care they better not have no
seven dollar amiibos for Zelda
that was tied for last so all right it
is what it is the robe have spoken
okay well whatever but uh yeah let's get
to him at Super chats is uh ready to
ride yes sir yes sir it's a rock so we
got drive by Joe five dollar Super Chat
uh well no actually that was just a five
dollar Super Chat thank you so much
and I saw people talking about the the
interview we had with Hi-Fi Rush the the
lead developer yes if you missed it at
the beginning don't worry we're going to
Premiere right after the podcast he used
to watch it if you did miss it because
uh they're you know I've seen a lot of
people in the chat saying they missed
yeah we got you John Johannes the
legendary high five Rush director Tango
games where we got you
then we got one two three four nine
eight seven six
who the hell
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
they talk so bad about Game Pass game
passes like your job paying your salary
up front without you doing any work plus
you can make bonuses and work overtime
who is going to say no to that exactly
big developers apparently
then we have Kento Wilson nine dollar
Super Chat Hi-Fi Rush is my game of the
year
hold my beard that's what Zelda said
absolutely the weight then we have Sith
Lord remember for six months Lord Braun
shout out to you sir oh what's
Lawrence it's race day it's almost time
to get ready for the Daytona 500 it's my
family's biggest enjoyment have a great
show I'll catch you all later you can
shout out to Daytona yeah I was I was
told by that yeah Lord yeah uh I
apologize to the people on the twitch we
still haven't like what happened on
Twitch is they read they disconnected
for some security thing and uh we
completely forgot to put that back in so
it sounds like it we'll be back on yeah
we get you we'll take we'll take it at
you we'll fix it
thank you sir they just got a salute
thank you salute to you sir we have Sith
Lord remember for six months Lord bronze
oh no actually I redid that one sorry
then we have Cheryl Walker remember for
one year put the crest in the chapter
chair Walker the Lord Bronze in the
building
okay this one I read from masok Easter
already for Cliffy B I read that one
already then we have Robert kellett two
dollars Super Chat don't you mean David
Daffy yo come on
respect the legend then we have Gerald
Mack member for two years five dollar
Super Chat all hail the IOP salute the
Lords and the lord of the real g-o-w
gears yo um Gerald Mack was on the game
of circle podcast yesterday if you
didn't get a chance to check it go back
and watch it yes
he made his debutable man nice the
legend of OG made this podcast of you
salute
and we have Simon Brandy five pound
Super Chat Cliffy and gears defined the
360 error for me there's no show him in
gaming anymore I know it like Cliffy
Phil should tempt him back I did read
this one before I'm sorry no you're good
I think it goes a lot of stuff with that
he wants to own his IPS and control his
life yeah so he learned you know when
you sell something that he created and
he was with and without any compensation
any anything yeah you know especially
how how much intertwined especially
being like yeah the person out there and
all the interviews the person like kind
of the face I can understand they all
their mindset they're like look we don't
legally owe him anything but I think
morally you should you should you you
should have paid them it did kind of
feel like if you read the book you you
kind of felt like when Cliff decided to
walk away from epic that it was like you
know Tim Sweeney was like okay you're
now my competitor
what sucks with that I guess his mindset
too was he's gonna feed someone that's
going to take that money and put it into
his own stuff too so that that's that's
not how
that was a father figure you understand
so there has to be a level of damn bro
you know it has to be there right and
the fact that you know he said you know
much they're capitalists yeah yeah oh I
hear you you know it's it's I I I I
wouldn't like it and and I understand he
he definitely did him wrong that was
insane no no no no
it's business it's business and very
quickly it became business this sucks
really bad yeah that's what the
friendship it gets it's extreme yeah
then we have THX 1138 two dollars with
chat I'm on the fence of not
repurchasing the last of us a third time
if you got a PlayStation 5 I'm going to
tell you do it do it do it it's
completely different do it do it then we
have Echelon seven the darkness remember
[Laughter]
Charlie Murphy
the celebration
happiness what did the five fingers say
to the face
Mark
ko3 black truth
I didn't even read I'm sorry I didn't
even read it
we just laughing remember for 25 Bus
Lord so this is the darkness again peace
to the Lords and Lord clippy shout out
to you absolutely
and we have ko3 black truth yeah
I was a PS dude until gears dropped
shout out to the OG yeah let's go that
way that's the one thing I I wanted to
bring up but I knew we were running out
of time it's like as it feel to be part
of a a franchise that people put in the
same line as like Halo like yeah yeah he
became a pillar yeah you know Halo kids
exactly yeah
bags then we have Mr uh no no I'm sorry
that we got a dreadful two dollar Super
Chat can I get a birthday song from
Cliffy and IOP I'm sorry we're not gonna
say brother but happy birthday
happy birthday
to you
[Music]
happy birthday
cool as hell happy birthday to you so
you didn't get it when Cliffy was here
but you got it sorry and I'm sure you
didn't want that burger you didn't want
that version I apologize you apologize
you know
then we have Mr Irishman member for 19
months Lord silver shout out to you sir
shout out to the man who gave us the
definitive third person shooter series
no other third person shooter is on the
level of Gears no you know what I
noticed um what's up I got to say this
right because somebody said that uh oh
y'all were so good when y'all was humble
when y'all wasn't pushing products one I
wasn't pushing focus on you
I wasn't at all I was just telling you
how great it is so if if you can go buy
it that's on you right because I don't
get paid for this but I'm I Cog send it
my way yeah yeah and I'm like you know
let me try and it works so sorry if you
know but you know what let's let's
address that let's address that
seriously and the fact of the matter is
guys you want us we want to grow yeah if
you did this is the game brothers and
sisters this is the game uh when it
comes to if we need if we want to grow
we want to become bigger than what we
are right now pause
um yeah and a lot of a lot of becoming
bigger has to do with you know just
people know who we are and you know
exactly you know what it was money it
was the fact that I was telling you
about the t-shirts you misinterpreted
what I said about T-shirts if I said you
know have on this pack shirt and if
you're in the Pax area trust me and you
happen to go to Pax I'm trying to make
sure that something's special like if
we're gonna have a real talk about it
like you know let's let's be on the
lowest we've been putting it down for a
long time a long time for years we did
it for no monetary no nothing and it's
like I remember yeah I just want to get
these balls off you know we try to get
the The Luminaries in the in the in the
community to create is the deaf we try
to get people that you've never heard
before you know from a content creator
standpoint even up income people it's
not just a numbers game so it's like be
damned if we're trying to grow this
brand and really get this thing out
there and all the way ask us for a
little support subscribe and hit the
like button if you like the products
that we we're promoted or affiliated
with like the Volare Advanced GG and
other things that we may talk about you
know what I'm saying it's just like
you're gonna find out we're gonna find
out like bro like we work very hard my
man all four four of us work extremely
hard to come here and show up on Sundays
I think it's not wrong to say hey this
is what we're doing and if you want to
it's an option that's all we said that's
all I do appreciate every Super Chat I
do appreciate every every chat period
like appreciate it I appreciate
everything I'm one of the only people
that you can find that's on YouTube that
has open DMS open video game joining I'm
playing with with everybody all day long
on fortnite
I don't hold my follows behind a oh yeah
you know I need to have nothing you only
got a thousand subscribers I can't talk
I can't mess with you one thing I will
say is after you guys uh you know a
couple people are being extra over my
opinions on Star food I haven't release
date I did close my DMs
[Laughter]
being attacked you know you guys were
looking for a Witch Hunt and you know I
shut up
you shut out the the people
I get it you know people sit there first
off for whatever we you know get
sponsored or do anything on the show
you're gonna know that our morals aren't
going to be manipulated and the thing is
is like look we we got to do what we got
to do in terms of monetary value you
know it's like I said The more money we
get the more we can actually promote
ourselves the more we can get in front
of more people because a lot of this is
the product again
if you don't got it
the thing is is oh a lot of this game is
numbers games yeah it's numbers games
and you know what you know when you when
you can actually go to these packs
events go to these E3 events that can
get you in front of people that no one's
heard from you get you content that's
not out there and what does that cost
that costs money and that costs a lot of
money you know what's funny is like the
the road to pack State I don't want
people thinking like we pocketing that
money it actually is costing us more
money to go to packs that I put on there
yeah yeah actually when we when we tell
you guys that everybody E3 oh God
could you give me the date please yeah
I'll give you the day and for the record
the Lord's go to these events in person
yeah
exactly bro like the the thing I can
honestly say about us too is like look
man we gonna do our little sponsored
post as you'll find out but it's like we
always gonna make it funny man we
we're going to push our sponsored posts
in the IOP way man we're gonna make it
fun when you hear sponsors we utilize
other things we promote we we actually
use the stuff yes
I'm sorry you have to get that out
Public Service Announcement Public
Service we're going to get that at
Friday
all right then we have free R Kelly once
again twenty dollar Super Chat one more
thing Cliff I Gotta Give it up to you
you're the goat Gears of War 2 was the
best game I ever played in high school
then Microsoft
only you can save it oh my God I I am
really glad he came on you know I
thought it was a long shot when I sent
that you know that was shout out to
shout out to to the to the realm he
never would have saw that if you guys
didn't share it
show interest because you guys shown
interest in those tweets that gets the
attention now oh who's this man every
time I come on Twitter that's 30
notifications
for sure and that was a great
conversation pick up his book yeah for
sure I don't I don't want to you know
break my arm off Pat myself on the back
but okay we did
I got that for half the price B what you
doing
like I said they fluctuate nah
I always do it I always uh move it to
the egress you know I like to have my
feet out and then I have probably one
dude next to me that dude the last time
he's put yeah but they but they also
they charge you for that they charge
thirty dollars it ain't 400 extra I feel
like I feel that anyway let's get this
one okay
where we have here I got the birthday
song then we got Hector Macho Man five
dollar Super Chat oh hell the Lords this
man helped me love Xbox because of gear
so I'm here to give him his flowers side
notes Slytherin gang or no gang
[Music]
I'm Slytherin yeah I actually
okay so there was a couple people asking
where is it where's the the Legacy
Hogwarts Legacy review I'm gonna be real
with you guys it's gonna be a minute
because most likely I'm going to be
reviewing a game in the next week and
that's got to come priority because they
actually sent me a review code so I got
to take their uh there's a little bit
more serious because you know when you
guys don't think you guys realize having
these games day one the before day one
is so vital to growth it's unreal and
you know it you know I might be
reviewing a game that you guys been
talking about what are you going into
your NDA dude
he want that bougie he want the green
here's the thing I don't want the bougie
with everything I just want the games
give me the red carpet continue
then we have a snowball backslash
remember for two years five dollar Super
Chat cliff and he's a question for Cliff
I'm sorry we didn't get to it but did
epic view Gears of War as a way to
license Unreal Engine to other
developers was it an earlier version of
what they did with fortnite no there was
a really good question about the story
narrative if there was anyone else that
they internally was going to kill but
ended up not going through the sport
yeah it was like I said guys like we
only have a certain amount of time with
these people yeah and then when he said
the NDA thing I got really I got nervous
with him too yeah
but the Unreal Engine remember there was
a game called unreal we never got to
that part but it was a game called
unreal right and that was in when when
listen he said very early on when he was
doing uh Jazz uh Jackrabbit that they
showed him the Unreal Engine said this
is going to be somebody that copped that
little man
this is gonna be uh was going to push
the industry forward so from the
beginning they already was going to
figure out how to monetize it and get it
they had to yeah unreal was a response
to Doom yes oh boy
it took out the water
real quick what's up we're gonna have
because we do have a shirt right now
it's with all of us in a line now I
would have envisioned something
different but I don't think that's going
to happen I think we're gonna have to
like communicate with people that
actually design
um you know stuff for actual shirts and
not just like logos but I do have one
that isn't what I wanted but I'm going
to go ahead and give it to uh the person
that does all that stuff because I do
feel like that shirt is it will be a
better shirt than the one we currently
have now uh but you know I I might
actually share the screen while I solve
Read Super chats and you get your guys's
opinion if you guys want this on a shirt
or not all right no doubt
pillows they will be coming here
relatively soon I think he said around
uh PAX East yeah
so you'll get it'll probably be shipping
at the end of next month and you'll get
to the March
UK people out there is ready to rock so
if you guys want a cop it is dead let's
put that link in the chat yes pillows
these pillows baby description too
my girlfriend's daughter has like
confiscated my pillow like that we'll
get another one we'll be doing something
hand to hand uh
pillows on the show floor
it's going to be bananas let's go
all right then we see
Tyson Lewis member for one year twenty
dollar Super Chat what's good family I
wish you all a blessed Sunday and
welcome to the realm Cliffy B that's
still a legend then we got ham ham solo
from tsws gaming all right requesting
the chat for Lord bronze thank you
brother appreciate the Lord yeah ham we
got the um he caught the little bit
t-shirt yeah what's up little man rocks
then we have let's play with each
other's joysticks
his name just for you
you do five dollar Super Chat
when are we getting the adult gears
dating Sim where you can have buff cogs
having relations with each other called
shafts
I'll be there day one yo oh he's
starting to conclusions
all I know is I don't hear my name he
pivoted and now you want buff cogs
[Laughter]
oh this is the show of new happiness
because
[Laughter]
we got ham from a tsws gaming once again
do remember two dollar Super Chat go hug
someone yes tell the people that you
love that you love them always
everybody
[Laughter]
let's understand personal space
then we have Robert Kelly Super Chat
Cliffy spitting bars men have emotions
too yes if you think you know who Cliff
lizinski is read that you know now
you'll find out
then we have Tom 909 two pound Super
Chat Brian Fargo should be up there or
king or King minus kit minus kid
I I guess uh eggplant okay
yes no we don't yeah
hey yo I'm out of here
I can turn your camera so so we got a
black boxing Kings five dollars okay
salute to the podcast love the show
hashtag
305.00
and we have Nintendo Taco five dollars
Super Chat they want to scream support
the devs or games they don't buy but
they don't want to support the podcast
they listen to every week shaking my
head listen we know it's not the vast
majority of people saying things like
that we know the best yeah
it's just it really we just want to put
it out there like when we tell you that
everything that comes into this podcast
goes right back into content for you
guys it's the truth
I'm going to share this picture while
you finish this these are the ones that
I'll actually do okay then we got hargit
chinny five dollar Super Chat it's sad
you have to justify trying to make money
keep hustling Brothers no need to feel
bad about it growing a business is work
and needs money thank you very much I
appreciate you for real
we have akw with the five pound super
chat hit that like button and save a
little puppy with one eye and that one
eye is crossed damn how you have one
crossover I like that one we gonna get
that done let me get that shirt yeah and
see originally I wanted this to be a
design that went on the entire shirt but
at this point it's like let's just put
it on a shirt because we do have a shirt
currently like you give a king
saying we talked about that a long time
ago but um I'm cool with the side eye
yeah
because what happened there this is what
I talked about because we're at the top
round table we're talking about playing
with my joystick is outside
oh yeah oh he's back oh man
so I I will be slowly getting this into
the uh the Teespring we'll try probably
take down the one that has all four of
us because I feel like this is a way
better one like my grand plan is to have
to replace the one where it's just
called and him have a like
we finish my statement as of right now
as of right now we have a we have a
shirt that has all four of four of us on
it and then we have individual ones that
have us on it so what I plan on doing is
this is the one that's going to report
uh replace all four of us and I want to
get shirts that's going to have us
individually drawn kind of like this in
their own scenarios like Cognito with
the the Shinobi maybe he you know he's
in like some Ninja pose on top of a
mountain or something and I want to
replace all those because my goal is to
get to to make shirts that you guys will
will want to buy not only to support the
podcast but you would rock at it yeah
but what's up with that thing that's
under cog's chin what happened oh yeah
that's my own
[Music]
[Laughter]
before he goes left time
Dragonheart Yobe remember for nights he
was Lord gold when it comes to the
gaming podcast space I honestly believe
iron Lords is the place to be stamped as
official official thank you thank you
for existing gentlemen you are all
legends hashtag peace love life thank
you thank you brother appreciate that
man I really do
and we got one bad mother ten dollar
Super Chat amazing interview friends
there's a lot to learn from these
stories to inspire and learn from from
in our own Endeavors more than just a
gaming podcast thank you thank you one
minute with the cliff man I'm proud of
that man like you we you know I honestly
had little hope that he could not like
censor his yeah but I thought it was
okay this is gonna be a pizza that's
what it is
I came in here he's like yo this isn't
something I feel comfortable doing but I
respect your guys's uh your your guys's
hustle so imma do what I can and it was
and it was a great it was a great talk
he's a professional professional
professional absolutely and and has
grown yes yes that's the thing right
that's the thing that he's so he's such
an evolved version of Cliffy it's crazy
how someone let that man make games
again
yeah yeah
it's gonna be on his terms
I personally feel like he has I get it
like Studios don't want to take risks on
projects they won't own and stuff but
it's just like man I honestly feel like
yo someone in this industry can make a
fantastic game just let Cliffy be Cliffy
I mean he didn't say that uh if he's
still conversations still being abused
come on still
listening
NDA for certain things there's no
dominance Maximus or really expensive
Spencer has split in many DM sorry you
never know I gotta see him on that
Summer Jam stage he told you that
PlayStation bag was a mistake
he was so Vindicated
I'm not gonna lie it broke my heart I
remember we did it it broke I remember
when the announcement came and me and
you got into it all
we don't see certain people do you know
cross-pollination either I like that but
you know you get a chance to understand
things yeah but he understood and I'm
glad he said it it was a mistake you
know I was chasing the numbers there was
a market leader I should have I should
have rocked with who I was rocking with
and you know what honestly I'm gonna
tell you this I think if he would have
rocked with us he would have rock with
him think that Lord break his Game Pass
what it did yeah no they didn't have
Game Pass don't get past it exist yes it
didn't existing Game Pass would existed
back then if if he thinks about it yeah
he can re-up that law Breakers I think
he's gonna throw it inside again well go
with another name do whatever but the
same formula because I was looking at
the gameplay yeah the gameplay is tight
it was it was a movement game yeah yeah
if if he does that same formula and
throw it inside a game
in chat feel free to put in the chat
just you know make it brief but if if
Microsoft did pull up was like yo we
want you back would you want him to go
to gears or would you want him to have
his own little Studio yeah
I know we haven't started the show
also y'all patting yourself on the back
don't get cocky out here they got people
in these streets that don't like it when
you know you got it they ain't got it
all right we don't got nothing
I don't know what you seeing but
I just love it when we when there's an
industry vet a legend come on the show
and they feel so comfortable and you
could tell it was comfortable and he was
just talking and I looked at that's what
I'm looking yeah for sure then we have
Gamers play HUD x x zero
I think my bathroom review code is a
priority over other reviews yeah let's
get them codes in well that that's the
truth because the you know the game
didn't launch it and it has to come out
it's it's very different when attic has
to go spend seventy dollars of his own
money because he asked for the review
code and it didn't show up no we're
gonna give the respect to the people
that shot it over their respected addict
so yes addict it's not even that it's
it's I would have no issue paying for it
if I just got it when the reviewers got
it like it's it's that that makes it
hard because once I especially something
like Harry Potter having to play it for
two three weeks at that point I'm still
gonna release it because we want the
coverage but I'm going to get a fraction
of the engagement in a fraction of the
traffic that I got if I had it on launch
you know I'm not entitled to one it'd
just be nice if I got it like yeah
that's right
and we have Lord Metroid two dollars to
pretend King is eating Popeyes
Popeyes a Malta with some Popeyes
biscuits and no bueno man well first of
all this is not a Popeye's biscuit stop
playing with me this is a macadamian
white chocolate oh
um
instead of crashing I'm here
then we got Hollywood rules five dollars
for chat happy Sunday fellas welcome
back King one away dragon is is is
inaccurately portraying BK I want him
voted off the island for putting mustard
we gotta take his BK standpoint his car
got it
nah bro
that's disgusting
yeah no no no no bueno no bueno let's
not do that no you wouldn't work
oh
and they jump okay give me a second now
you go
and we have Hollywood so much
okay Soma King with the four pound Super
Chat cheers dance cheers to you as well
sir I appreciate that absolutely and we
have let's play with each other's Choice
five dollar super Jack sorry Cognito I
know I said Cog in the chat and I
respect you're sexy but Sav is the only
one for me
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh shout out to Crazy Lou gaming oh
what's up all the way from the Dominican
Republic
accept me
something crazy
oh no got the cigars
Crazy Lou thank you yeah good dude this
is one of the the gifts that I got so
far so this is crazy Lou we'll get to
this whole time
[Music]
I need that shirt
then we have Matt without fear remember
for 13 months Lord silver great to see
the Cliffy bee shot paying off the Lords
are off to a great start in 2023. you
guys have no idea yes sir
thank you brother appreciate that much
appreciate it we have the rubber knob
the five dollar Super Chat this is the
only podcast I choose to financially
support show some respect and hit that
like button save the kittens from the
spiky bushes yes no thank you man you
really doing the Lord's work appreciate
it brother appreciate you hold on let me
roll back because we did get jumped
um
okay we have clutch man oh one five
dollars to be tap can someone make a
basketball game or a mode with these
hilarious NBA Instagram Tick Tock edits
I might actually play it have a great
show fellas thanks that's that's funny
and
um this comes from rip snorter okay whoa
what what's the name
go follow these guys he sends me and I
and I have to go take it get it um
yeah it's a signed autograph Manny
Pacquiao oh that's fire that's fire
um this is definitely I'm going to uh
Michael's and going to go put it in
beautiful wow put that up I do
appreciate it it's stolen from a very
far Place
uh coordinations
the only good thing I ever got in the
mail from this podcast was was King's
knees
you got the shea butter version
then we got fonze gaming five dollar
Super Chat mustard on Pizza what the
hell yeah anyway he's a proud of you
Brothers
communicated
the one away Dragon TV yeah that's
communicated yeah
we have Gamers play Hot xero once again
five dollars for chat Lord SOB is
pronounced zero okay HUD zero excuse me
hot zero okay
love you Lords of the realm the baby has
grown large getting Cliffy B is a huge
get hashtag State awesome hashtag game
on
I will not mess it up again Lord zero we
got him we good we're good we're caught
up all right let's go get this show
started uh
Patriot question of the week dip down
games and there's only one though
there's only one there's only one all of
the Lords are trapped in a rule do the
reasons we're trapped there's no reasons
there's only one way to get out all of
you have to come to an agreement
which one of these is wiped from history
past present and future
bungee rock star epic or The Legend of
Zelda series and only way we could get
out this room of all of us have to agree
on this one let's say fair because I
feel like I'm not saying
rock store Rockstar epic or Legend of
Zelda series I gotta go a rockstar I
gotta go I gotta go with epic what what
I know
I think we can all all three of us can
survive without rockstars
we need to convince songs the other
super chats are getting ridiculous
no we gotta get that over here
what would it take man to get you to get
this rule but you you hold it up y'all
are bugging I'm gonna go with addict on
Epic
oh we don't have
y'all bro
I feel like someone would would rise in
its place
no Unity hell no
listen listen
about the developers they take so long
to make the games anyway yeah right
that's 10 years 20 years ago
why can't it be bungee
Xbox with our budgies
all right so we're not getting out of
this room we're dying we're dying in
this room okay
I'm stubborn we're gonna die together
I will put it in I will put a poll yes
in the chat and the the realm will
decide yeah
but here's the thing we're not deciding
that let's be honest
this is
this is literally all of our back jokes
side jokes in one poll yeah that's the
reason Zelda they didn't say the Zell
like Nintendo because he didn't want
Nintendo yeah he said we probably they
knew what he was doing and I'm not
playing by his rules
it was a good run thank you
that is a very hard four-way poll that's
very much very hard I don't know how he
knew I was gonna go with epic though
yeah that kind of though plus clear for
you you've been playing fortnite so much
oh yeah yeah that's not it that's see me
with the Epic engine yeah unreal Powers
everything yeah that's that's the
industry yeah you have no Microsoft
moving on we're gonna get this time we
got Robert Kelly
is crazy
um good and keep in mind that that's on
patreon if you guys uh join the patreon
you can ask us questions at the
beginning of every show yes I thought
about putting one for the members but
you guys get you guys get to ask us a
question every month with that uh
members Chat thing to the patreon
um dip down has been looking down doing
his thing I love the questions brother
thank you all right are we good and I'll
put the patreon to this topic now sir
we'll start soon
finally get to the show but to be fair I
don't think this is going to be like a
crazy show yeah so this is King's topic
um so it looks like the shot
thegamesindustry.biz uh had an article
out what would a Game Pass dominated
landscape look like and uh this is
opinion piece they put out nobody's
surprised by Microsoft's admission that
game pass cannibalizes paid sales and
many companies are untroubled but a
potential Monopoly remains a threat for
others they go on to talk about what's
going on the CMA Microsoft submission
that on Game Pass affects sales at least
for a year and this has been a talking
point as far as a you know a world where
Game Pass could dominate so King your
thoughts is your topic sir okay so um
after reading the article and I mean of
course the headline is like clickbaity
in in its sense
I walked away from it
feeling that he was right
um
uh you know a lot of times we get
articles and we don't read it we just
read a paragraph and we're coming in
without bias and uh this week I felt uh
you know after drinking some Focus
product placement description code iron
Lord yeah
I was able to uh get through this
article with with little to no uh
problems
and comprehending everything because I
was super focused yeah crazy focus and
um
what he's worrying about is the
the connection to the big
Studios with the consumer right because
he brings up steam as Steam is a
storefront that people get to Peddle
their Wares but Game Pass is really the
service and their Wares are in there and
they really don't have any control of
what's inside the service you just
purchase a service and there's a
disconnect because Microsoft becomes the
proprietary owner of how you get the
service so he feels that is a fear of
once Microsoft controls that and it
becomes successful
it changes how we see things like sales
of games same thing with movies and uh
how we uh purchase music remember when
Eminem was sold uh 10 million copies of
a song of a album that'll never happen
again
right I'm seeing uh artists now sell 40
000 and they view that as a success
opposed to before you had to sell a
million copies of an album and that you
was when we went Platinum Status so we
won't have these artists go platinum
they will have to go platinum streaming
they won't never go platinum on direct
sales anymore or physical copies and
that's going to be the decline in the
physical copies as the companies start
to uh fix their self and write this off
my question is when y'all read this uh
what was your opinion of the piece it
was a very well written piece in my
opinion of it and I tend to agree with
all the stuff that he said by the end of
the piece and I'll give my rebuttal at
the end no doubt uh addict get a chance
to read or just the whole idea of uh
Game Pass uh potentially cannibalizing
sales and discussion about Game Pass
being dominant
I mean look I do think that I mean I've
said from the start uh Game Pass does
cannibalize cells but that's what
Microsoft wants you know they they
they've encouraged you multiple times
subscribe to Game Pass why would you
realistically buy uh any especially
first party stuff in the platform when
you could just get it on Game Pass and
that's okay because Microsoft wants it
that way they want to be that you know
okay we got these games to deliver uh so
instead of you know charging you know
anywhere from 30 to 70 dollars and these
uh for these couple months we want to
take money from you all year long yeah
uh so you know it is what it is uh I do
think that you know these were
statements that was tooken years ago too
and obviously you know the landscaping
and things change everything's not going
to be like it was in 2017-18 so it is
what it is on that end but I do want to
point out that we've seen you know what
it might capitalize when it comes to
something like the first party stuff
Garfield red fall I don't think people
give it props for others incidences
where I'm a hundred percent convinced
that game pass saved the games outright
um that game that game probably wouldn't
have done as well as it did when it came
out and now not only did it come in Game
Pass it was cross play yeah so I'm
playing it on here and I got someone on
Playstation yo I can't uh you know it's
not a game but guess what they buying
that if they want to play with me they
don't got Game Pass steam same thing so
you know what you see lacking and stuff
I do think that people don't see the
other end of the spectrum they just want
to look at the first party stuff
Microsoft expects the first party stuff
to go through uh that's because they
have Game Pass they you mean to tell me
Microsoft didn't say you know what uh
it's like Calvin and they're like oh do
you guys honestly think that you know I
think people are still going to buy your
games why would they when's the last
time you saw someone that has a Netflix
subscription say you know what
stranger things is fire I'ma wait for it
to come on DVD let me get the box set
like look like people obviously that's
why I'm very uh you know adamant about
you know if you when it comes the only
thing I will say when it comes to Game
Pass
is the small indie games they get you
know the uh the names uh tunic the uh
what's the one with the the one that we
played last year and what was that game
called uh everybody saves the world
everybody says the world no it's the
death Reaper one I can't remember
oh yeah games like that man you know if
you really revive with those those IPS
go buy it man even if you're just gonna
give it away to something because I feel
like those games that additional income
you're going to lead to a better product
going down the line
solve your thoughts on the article Game
Pass cannibalizes sales and Game Pass be
too dominant
yeah I mean at the end when you look at
the context of it right it's a document
from the the CMA sort of findings and
whatever much like but yeah bro you
can't take 100 of this right but but
what it is is like you just like
PlayStation right it behooves Microsoft
to look as quick as possible in this
documentation you have to look
PlayStation is the most dominant we
can't touch them much like the you know
PlayStation was like oh Call of Duty
nothing can touch it there's nothing
like it we can't even hope in a million
years to kind of franchise like Call of
Duty like it's the same so it's the same
sort of sort of hyperbole that again
when you're talking to people that don't
understand the gaming industry like that
you need to put out those kind of
examples in order to show that a you're
willing to acquiesce to whatever they
need for this deal to go through and B
that you are you you you're you're fine
with admitting that you're in a weekend
position or a position of less power so
admitting that game pass cannibalizes
game sales is just part of that and the
fact matters is funny because I remember
years ago when we first heard when we
first heard the idea and coming from
Phil and coming from the higher ups over
at Xbox that the idea that game pass
actually promotes more sales I'm like I
to myself I'm like I'm that just sounds
backwards to me right it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense to me right and if
you think about it
they'll never say that it promotes more
sales on Xbox what he said was that it
promotes more sales generally which if
you're somebody right you know what
they're specific instance though he said
I think it was Forza Horizon right
before specifically which when they
asked him is where the quote is coming
from I'm seeing right
okay you got to keep in mind a lot of
these games now especially the forza
franchise they have that like three-day
access Early Access if you buy like the
deluxe edition so if you have a bunch of
people buying those because they don't
want to wait for the game pass drop I
could see how at that time you could
probably get more of a result at the end
of it because I don't think Forza was
selling like that like as well as it
does back then too well you know what I
think the the the promotion and sales
and they don't tell you that the sales
of the game I think it's the sales of
the DLCs that for the game right so Game
Pass to give you the base but if you
want this little extra stuff you got to
go buy this and let's say a million
people or 20 million people tried a
vampire Survivor and then they noticed
that it was DLC the Moonlight DLC two
dollars if only 10 million buy it that's
a huge success
yeah
and I think that I think that Forza was
was the first time Hot Wheels was
implied into yeah before his brand yeah
I don't know so for me it is that thing
of like it it's it's selling it's
because it's in front of so much so many
more eyes because it's in Game Pass if
you're somebody who absolutely is like
I'm I'm on another platform I'm not
getting game pass it makes no sense for
me to get an Xbox no matter how good a
deal is but if you're hearing the buzz
about the game and there's so many more
people talking about it because of Game
Pass you're gonna buy it on another
platform it's just it's just what's
going to happen so in general I can now
I can understand the idea of Game Pass
promoting sales elsewhere does it make
100 sense that it would not promote
sales on Xbox unless like addict
mentioned you have you know that the
incentives to get it four days early or
DLC and stuff and stuff like that yeah
it makes 100 sense yeah and you know
sometimes we forget though that that
during that entire period that it's
there if you want to purchase it you can
also purchase it at a 10 discount right
if you wanted to purchase purchase it
and forget about the Game Pass stuff so
to me again it is what it is it
absolutely is true we went crazy when we
were like I don't understand this
concept because the concept was broader
than than just the Xbox ecosystem and
and in that looking at it under that
microscope it does make sense but the
fact of the matter is on the Xbox
ecosystem if you're in it if you're
really in it chances are you got games
exactly and and that's like to attic's
point that's what Microsoft wants
because in the long term when you do
have a successful Subscription Service
Long Term you're ending up paying for
games over a 10-year span that you know
little by little that money goes to
whatever it doesn't specifically go to
certain games but when you when you add
it up you paid for these games that are
60 70 retail games five times over
whatever during the course of so it's
just it's they're playing the long game
right and the hope is that
they can sustain the long game with 70
or with a 70 product because I think the
difference is when you talk about the
difficulties and the things that people
see about how it could change the gaming
industry for the worse right a lot of
the criticisms are that it's going to
change it for the worse it's just the
fact that it's not the same paying a
subscription service for a movie that
whatever would cost you however much
money to pay for it and to watch it in a
movie theater or whatever 30 bucks or
whatever as opposed to
[Music]
a 70 dollar product that costs 200
million dollars to make and it you know
it's there's a certain amount of Revenue
coming back that's expected and you know
does that work in the long term for a
product that requires that much money
going into it and I think I those are
valid concerns but again we won't ever
know the answer to that until it plays
out yeah and
that's it no absolutely well said um
yeah pretty much the same thing I
thought this was kind of funny to me I
mean I saw you know the whole
thing about cannibalizing sales and you
know to me it was just like a no-brainer
of course it's going to cannibalize it
it's a digital subscription they've
changed their model to a subscription
service that one is twofold one is to
get people to subscribe to it so if
Hi-Fi Rush launches into a service right
and it's a quality game of course people
are going to subscribe to Game Pass in
the majority most likely will do that
now yes you will have instances where
people will buy the retail or buy the
Steam and other stuff that can promote
other sales and based on the variety but
that's what's to be expected I think
the thing that's funny to me is like I'm
seeing like there's this gotcha moment
see in 2018 yeah people are reaching
with this yeah like I'm just I don't
understand that mentality because Phil
Spencer's lying yeah because he's like
all right in 2018 he's talking about for
Forza Horizon specifically in that
instance and that it led to more gay
sales but we don't we know and I don't
think that applies to every game in Game
Pass right so my thing is for each
situation it's different right there's
going to be some depending on the the
developer relationship as far as the
Game Pass deal that they got because the
way we the way it's explained is that
they enter the service right they and
let's say for example oh that game like
a real fire that you got over there
that's right
so if you're a developer and you know
the amount of risk and cost right and
you're hoping that your game goes viral
you're hoping that it sells all these
units whatever and then Microsoft has
like here's our projection we'll give
you this bag that's a security blanket
for deficit okay you're taking us giving
us a bag we can relax right then on top
of that we thought it is right and we
exactly finish it again because we know
the cost of development so if they get
it into the service and then you got
what is it 30 million or 24 whatever it
is that's in Game Pass and then they say
okay you have the potential virality of
all these built-in subscribers just by
launching it into the service that is
attractive to something now on the flip
side let's just say for example you take
two right and you like yo we got you
know grand theft or whatever right and
Mike's like yo that game look good and
you might say you know we we good you
don't say we we want to sell everywhere
we think our bag could be bigger right
and I see like it's what soft said
Microsoft is playing the long game so
all this I get it a lot of people are so
hung up on sales sales and NPD and even
me like I was in that bag with I'm like
damn like you know why they didn't chart
whatever the service is countering
intuitive to that exactly the service is
literally they don't can't not that they
don't care about sales but they are more
focused on you subscribing to the
service changing that 25 million to 30
million to 100 million so now you go
back to Rockstar right I got you at it I
go back to Rockstar and when Rockstar
let's say I'm just making them the enemy
for that just for jokes but like they
killed us in that room
was what it was even though he'd be
putting 2K in Game Pass but whatever
yeah so now let's say game passes is at
100 million
and now you like yeah you really suck
what's up 100 million off rip can play
your game or you know what I'm saying
then it changes the conversation so
they're playing the long game the thing
I don't like and I'll give it to you at
it is that I'm just not from this era of
badging something that is saving me
money right that is a deal right and
then I'm pro pro Dev so if the devs we
have the devs or they say yo this deal
was amazing for us we got peace of mind
we got security we saw all this virality
I wish that the developers speak more
actively right but they did though like
like from the article
he wasn't bashing it until like you know
when I got to the end of it you know I
saw his outline of it but there are
developers and what he's saying is
smaller developers are championing like
oh yeah and it doesn't make sense in the
context of this this opinion piece it
does make sense but at the same time
from cog's standpoint there are people
that's on the outside that's using this
as a talking piece too bad right and
that's not yeah and they didn't read it
right and my thing is that's the part
I'm just not with this we are going to
try to bash something that is beneficial
as giving Gamers a deal and what you
call as a deal like you like to me
there's concern if you if you be happy
yeah like they're being charged more
money exactly to me I could understand
if you want to understand the business
of it it's like I just want to know how
it works long term but my thing is
that's Microsoft and their money and
their their coffers for them to worry
about all I care about is one as a gamer
the immediate deal I'm getting the
benefit I'm getting into all the
developers getting taken care of that's
my main concern if those two check boxes
are happening it's up to Microsoft to
feel it's the angel expression I've used
before I don't go to the car dealership
to say yo this deal is too good you
giving me this month and I need to find
out why it's a hundred dollars off this
mother why are you giving me six months
free this month like no one's doing that
so to me people can equivalent to like
signing up for Netflix but like I want
to pay you the first time yeah it's like
to me people have some let's be ready
some people have a certain agenda
because they don't like certain
platforms right and all of a sudden
there's this concern we gotta see no
one's doing that with no other product
in life you go and someone said yo you
getting this deal for this versus this
I'm good it's equivalent to going on
Black Friday and tell them people yeah
it's Black Friday stuff how are you guys
long term surviving off Black Friday
Walmart
we need to see the number
yeah
is you can sit there and compare them
all you want but what you don't do and
what I see people get confused are is
you're not comparing the actual business
practices because there's two entirely
different business models you want to
compare two different business models to
the actual ways that they earn Revenue
exactly a subscription service has an
entirely different business model than
your standard Selling Stuff business
model right that that's the funny part
it's like they want to compare the two
and when you bring it up oh that doesn't
count what you mean it doesn't count
look I get it in defense of this group
look I get it we from that era like yo
sales software sales means they're
everything the MPD means everything
Hardware Sales everything man that's not
the game Microsoft's Place
Microsoft has changed the game from the
beginning let's be let's be real yeah
they've
forced you to have ethernet connection
um they forced the hard drive on you
yeah all these stuff they forced online
on you all these stuff that y'all was
raving against no we don't need this
dude
why is it on always they're spying on me
they have cameras meanwhile we got Alexa
okay that means they should be all right
now with cameras the big person that
needs to be online to play stuff you're
the same person that need that either
[__] if you didn't have it you
wouldn't be on please I don't need to be
hardlined in because the way my
connection is you know I can't do the
Wi-Fi you
people
what do you mean what do you mean I do
know who I'm talking about you people
um I think the the part that annoys me
king is they're having the wrong
arguments the wrong debates instead of
talking about something that saves you
no money say y'all I'm concerned
subscription models is going to you know
encourage them to make games more grindy
because they want more microtransactions
at it like they don't have the right
conversations well well uh um attic
we're growing up in a in a decade or age
where
when we show you our stack it meant
something when they show you show me
yourself
let's see that build bro he who has the
most toys win
right and Microsoft flipped that on his
head you can have all the toys in the
world
all we want is your eyeballs
you know I mean I can take care of your
eyeballs on the next pin the name
all I want is your engagement right and
when Microsoft said engagement people
said well it's because you're losing
right of course of course yeah so what
y'all winning y'all winning and selling
stuff all right we were we gonna win and
having people view our stuff see and
this is what Sony has to capitalize on
they have to have that subscription
service mean something it has I talked
to Cog the other day I said yo I'm
playing The Last of Us right now and I
said it's nine dollars right I I got in
confused because I had jumped out the
window come on right there on the phone
I heard him that's there what wait a
second nine dollars hold on let me get
that now
when there's value there's going to be
purchasing when there's value there's
going to be engagement Cog wasn't
pulling up that app until I said that
yeah so if the word of mouth means that
there's value inside your service then
that people will gravitate to it what
I'm saying for Sony is stop being all
hung up on on selling sales numbers it's
a talking point for you people
yeah I gotta remove that away and get
back to the engagement because they're
turning into engagement now you guys are
just fighting against the storm and real
quick so the funny thing is like they
talk about the negatives that game pass
is done you know cannibalizing sales
let's not talk about the fact that game
pass is probably the only reason the
original final fantasies came to the
platform let's start talking about the
only reason that Kingdom Hearts came to
the platform one and two because they're
able to use to Leverage What about
Persona what about Yakuza all of these
were never on Xbox until game pass
because Microsoft was able to use Game
Pass as a leverage to get people oh you
know I know you guys these games don't
sell the greatest on our platform we'll
give you a bag and you'll have access to
millions of people to hopefully gain a
following after this all right you're
gonna say sorry you don't say something
so let me play Devil's Advocate let's go
let's see I hate The Devil's Advocate
let's say for reasons for reasons Game
Pass plateaus okay right and it's and it
stops growing right oh me me and Dirk
had this conversation how are you going
okay
and then it doesn't then it's not
sustainable anymore right you can't
sustain these humongous these humongous
first party games or whatever you can't
really sustain it you're not bringing in
the money to bring in the big
third-party games and the small stuff
isn't enough to keep people engaged and
you start losing uh subscribers
then what do you think and again it's a
hypothetical situation but
hypothetically that happens do you think
the people that are arguing that game
pass is killing the industry because
it's teaching people not to want to buy
games do you think in that scenario they
were right or do you think
that it is a situation where like like
King was talking about the value just
wasn't there again and the idea that
it's going to Plateau may be a little
far-fetched but imagine if you you're
anything can happen but if you're in the
let's say you're in it just for the
first party stuff right and let's say
Microsoft just drops the ball damn near
every single first party thing and you
don't see the value in it and the third
party stuff doesn't doesn't appeal to
you as much because the games aren't as
big or whatever and the small stuff you
could find another platforms whatever
the case
so that's because again that's the
argument the opposite argument is being
made right absolutely that you're
teaching people in the long term now I'm
not buying that I'm not giving them
money for that right so what are the
thoughts now it's a good it's a good
point look we don't know we can't
predict the future right we don't know
how this thing is going to play out yes
we know Microsoft's the coffers are big
they got the Scrooge big money you know
what I'm saying we understand that but
at the same time it's an obligation on
them to continue to put quality products
in the service and that's why I'm Lord
acquisition because the reason being is
you have to have Studios making games we
just saw what happened with them in 2022
when everything fell on Bethesda and
then we started two delays Starfield
reform and then nothing else was ready
but imagine if you have Studios right
and then you have the more producer that
different cadences because news flash
games take long to develop I don't know
where people thinking it's like the two
to three year thing and where these
these games taken four to five years
exactly they're big and there's a lot of
risk so only the best Studios get games
in the third years exactly we just had
John Johannes we highly advise you
listen to it our interview he said Hi-Fi
Rush took five years right so again if
you got that Cadence between releasing
creating games right you're gonna need
Studios to feed this this service and it
behooves Microsoft not only to have that
to also maintain quality right to have
quiet you see again when in 20 I usually
what is it uh 2021 as their as like an
example year if Game Pass goes according
to plan so to speak right you have
Psychonauts two uh Microsoft flight
simulator you know you have um what you
call it uh Halo and Forza Horizon right
it all in the same year right highly
rate day what was it Metacritic of the
year that year right yeah publisher of
the year so it goes to show you if the
if the vision is executed correctly
right and they have quality games of the
service you could grow the service so it
that's going to be on them all I all I
was saying is you know pretty much like
let's one look at what's being offered
as a consumer first is this does this
provide you good value right be all I
care about is developers these people
who make games we're gonna get into my
topic afterwards about for Access right
for axis makes turn based and it looks
like right now you know midnight signs
didn't do well I think they would love
to be at a service like a pass
I think just theoretically right there's
going to be certain things that it could
it could help them so that's why I think
I think to your overall question
that's on Microsoft to to deliver the
quality to have that content drop in
that Cadence and for them to execute and
if they do that then they will achieve
their goal of of generating more
subscribers because that's the game
they're playing letting you play
anywhere you want to play and then in
the actual subscription service so
that's what I'm out with it yep
no well after after reading it and I
understand that his concern was probably
for the bigger people like Rockstar and
stuff like that where they have a
disconnect with the consumer uh he
wasn't saying that
um that it was a The Game Pass was bad
Game Pass is a direct uh how can you say
it a direct threat to the bigger guys
for the smaller guys The Upfront bag
helps right uh it helps give them
exposure it helps puts them in front of
the audience it helps give them a
cushion it helps the smaller guys in the
long term it hurts the bigger guys
because they don't have the direct sale
to the consumer they don't have that
direct communication to the consumer if
the game is in it so you can see why
Rockstar would be resistant because it
will lose that line of sight with the
consumer
if they put their stuff in Game Pass
he's looking at a dystopian world in in
the views of it's just being game
passing Game Pass becomes dominant right
you know with the whole conversation
around the um the cell of the ABK right
right uh if Call of Duty is inside Game
Pass and it doesn't cause Microsoft
anything I think but they already did
they 70 billion up front right which is
a ton of money but over a period of time
that would pay for itself right now if
they give Sony which I heard it was a a
misinformation that was put out
yesterday where they offered Sony 15
years no the information was they
offered them 10 adult film five then
they offered them ten you know and
somebody came up with the number 15 and
said Sony turned it down no they're in
quiet talks in the background trying to
iron this stuff out now
them giving a Call of Duty to the
PlayStation platform even if it's in
PlayStation Plus
they still have to pay Microsoft right
so those sales uh still is going to
generate Revenue in Microsoft ecosystem
that's the conversation here once once
Microsoft is the owners of something
that big that would generate that type
of uh Revenue do you continue to support
this thing do you hold out in hopes that
your favorite game because this happens
to me all the time ends up in the
subscription service because how many
times have you purchased something and
then a week later inside and that forms
a reluctance in purchasing that's fair
so yeah there's a cascading effect right
Game Pass and how it forms trepidation
and purchasing how it forms a barrier
between larger uh conglomerates and the
consumer and in this body of the the
piece this is where he gives you his
opinion on how it's affecting that's
fair and I'll just jump in real quick I
don't know right I agree with that
that's something that to monitor also to
monitor that I don't think no one's
talking about is that if Game Pass gets
to that level of success right and
there's this curated list that goes in
and out you know some State people get a
year a one year deal two-year deal the
concern I have is maybe for the Indie
guy who doesn't get the game pass back
right and then how does it affect those
who can't get into service and you don't
have those extra you know lights on you
so to speak so that's that's something
you know to look at long term yeah I
know a lot of people try been trying to
get their games in Game Pass like a lot
I agree I agree but no that's a good
point that's a good point because it
does it does make people say okay you
know what you know damn you know like if
I wait I might be able to get you know
what I'm saying such such a game you
know what I'm saying a couple months
later
so yeah we got to see what it is and I
think at the end of the day too these
people were saying that they weren't
guaranteed to buy it if it wasn't in
that service or if it wasn't that serve
it's like you know it it we don't live
in a universe where we know what game
would have sold well without Game Pass
obviously there's there's things that
could go into place that I think could
really be beneficial but like I said do
we honestly think outriders would have
got support as long as it was if it
wasn't in Game Pass access to millions
of people and it just we don't know and
the positive standpoint is let's just
say you don't go in Game Pass you kind
of bomb and now Game Pass can kind of
give you a second virality you know what
I'm saying if you put it in the service
later and it's like you said some devs
do that right like they won't take the
Game Pass back up front they'll sell it
whatever and then all of a sudden later
it'll come back it'll get like a second
life because it is service so it's all
individuals open on the studio and then
you got stuff like the show Show's never
been on an Xbox platform and because the
game pass it has access to millions of
people that can actually make up for
that lost time in that building a
viewership or a fan base on a platform
that didn't exist on for for years and
years yeah that's a good point that's
all I got King's got more no no no
definitely that was about it I mean I
just thought it was a very well written
piece and for people to bash it without
reading it was uh kind of kind of messed
up because I saw it and I said well let
me see because this week was light on
news yeah and I said well let me dig
deep thank God Cliff he came up through
we would have made it work regardless no
doubt no doubt yeah sorry super chats I
think we need to do yeah so let's read
these super chats first we got a couple
this is hilarious you only got three we
got the rubber knob for two years five
dollars yes 100 100 it damages sales but
does it damage overall profits the
average gamer will only buy a couple of
games a year other than Cod and FIFA yep
that's true no doubt then we have the
Caucasian Negro spiritual oh my gosh
what's going on
two dollars Super Chat what's happening
my fellow brothers harambe yo what's
going on what's going on what's
Happening oh man then we have Rob the
Don 202 five dollar Super Chat it's
funny I've never seen think pieces of
how free to play ruined direct sales
because free to play has a more direct
impact on younger Gamers and does more
harm in my opinion
quite today wow wow that's interesting
that's what else we got stuff
that is it so
before we move into our next topic this
is for all of you out there who uh who
feel that the iron Lords are sold out uh
yeah absolutely right
100 100 bags 100 so with that with that
I'm gonna ask my brothers a question
gentlemen
how do you feel
when I say the word
is
I don't know what you're talking about
I'm speaking in my normal voice why are
you saying the words how do you feel
when I say the word
sure
do you feel like do you feel smart you
get excited when I say the word honey
I feel like my girlfriend about to hit
you up and say stop
I don't understand what you guys you
guys are really bugging out like I don't
this is my normal Timber my normal voice
I yeah I just all I'm asking you is like
what do you think about when you say you
know who you hear honey I'm gonna ask
you to stop
[Laughter]
I don't know about different I'm the
same right so I listen listen guys get
your minds out of the gun water when I
talk about honey I'm talking about
saving 100 savings because of course
today's episode is sponsored by none
other than honey
my voice just drops when I when I when I
say it you know so honey is the easy way
to save when you're shopping on your
iPhone oh or your computer thanks to
Honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart
now let me tell you how it works imagine
that you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites and then you check out
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is click on the button that
says apply coupons you wait a couple of
seconds and Honey's gonna search for the
very best coupon it can find for the
site that you're on then if they find a
working coupon you apply it to your to
your uh to your checkout and that's it
your prices are going to drop so I'm
gonna tell you
for me I've been using honey for a long
time and I know a lot of us have been
using it for a long time
for me nine times out of ten I'm using
honey to buy food lady Saab knows that
on the weekends we have one rule we
don't cook
yeah there's no cooking in this house on
the weekend right so what do we do we're
ordering out whether it's Pizza whether
it's Chinese food whether it's sushi
we're going to go to our favorite
delivery site pick out what we want we
go in there go into checkout as soon as
you want to check out honey pops up and
it's either it depends on whatever the
coupons available are right but it's
going to find the coupons available it's
going to pick out the very best one for
you and I'm gonna be honest man I can
save anywhere from five dollars to
Fifteen dollars if it's percentages
it'll be a 10 discount sometimes a 20
discount and this is every single time
that I go on and purchase food online so
so how do I do it again it is you just
have to go in to your to your browser
add it as an add-on in your browser and
what's going to happen is anytime you go
to a shop things like you put something
in the chat in your checkout it's going
to tell you hey there is x amount of
coupons available it's going to go
through all the ones to make sure it
eliminates the ones that aren't
available and then from the ones that
are available if they they do have valid
ones it's going to give you the best
possible deal you can possibly get right
I just downloaded it right now there you
go I mean it it's it's super easy I know
a lot of people been using it for a lot
of years I've been using it for a lot of
years so when I say that it like I'm
happy and proud to be endorsing this you
have no idea so let me just that easy
that was crazy
just to clarify you're saying that honey
gonna search the internet and save you
money for for no easy for no effort one
you just add people downloaded you just
have to add it to your browser and that
is it so with all of that said let me
give you a little some details of maybe
you didn't know so honey it just doesn't
work on your desktop right it's just not
only for your desktop browser if you
have an iPhone it works on your iPhone
too same thing you know Safari could be
a little funny whatever you just
installed it on Safari and then just
save it on the go as well so it doesn't
really matter where you are you can save
no matter what so
what can I say right if you don't
already have honey you're gonna you're
straight up missing out you're straight
up missing out and then by getting it
you're gonna do yourself a solid and
you're going to be doing your favorite
podcast a solid and support us so
how how how do you get down with this
you go to get PayPal honey for free
right and it's PayPal honey now because
you know PayPal put the ring on it a
long time
PayPal honey PayPal and put that ring on
it for free at joinhoney.com iron Lords
I repeat that is joinhoney.com
yeah and to be honest with you guys like
I'll just get stuff apart like man you
you save money doing nothing doing
nothing so with that I finish off with
honey
[Laughter]
give me that link go ahead not to
mention get games aren't cheap man so
you saving other areas you video life
you can you know you can buy more games
exactly oh you have a new fan of honey
oh boy oh boy I do oh boy yeah someone's
really excited about this read that
later I don't want to read that later
okay let's get the link in there let's
get the link in there you know what I'm
saying
adequate would you mind doing that
because I just yeah yeah copy that
sentence and put that in there because
you gotta say somebody with the Lords
you know what I'm saying let's see let's
see these superchastic here we just got
a cold with hilarious
that won't
say what's up
we got let's let me play with King's
joysticks
Super Chat let me press that GP button
kingy boy
I need a general purpose button what's
up
what's going on see now you got married
the only thing I'll say is if anyone
tries to make that kind of account for
me my girlfriend fights
she can't fight the win
make sure you make an attic play with
Alex Joyce
you hit me with his joystick
then we got c1b you two dollar Super
Chat get that honey
oh
I'm sorry we can't do it can't do the
full metal
jacket.com okay okay
that's how we do it I gotta say I got
the PayPal one I just did that joints
just straight through Straight though
okay cool I'm just looking around
because I pay for stuff a lot with
PayPal anyways it don't matter exactly
then we have let's play with each
other's joysticks
his cousin is bothering me when
I think of honey I think about licking
the rim whoa whoa
I hope to God that these are two
individual people and this isn't the
same person
one of them one of them is from the UK
so it's definitely two different people
unless you know you you know you're
putting up a VPN or something like that
I'm safe solve is in danger
yeah my person got to take a flight
your taxis dollars are definitely going
to security detail for me as I walk the
floor yeah
was just you know it's like like we said
guys right there man you know like well
at the end of the day man this is this
is costing you nothing it's gonna save
you money go go Stick It Rock with the
honey man
I've been rocking 100 for a long time
when we when we got this I was like oh
okay yes we get to support things that
we already use because honey it's like
the easiest thing it just pops up and
it's Gonna Give You discounts every
single time so yeah I just integrated
into my browser right now with the
extension YouTube this is cool no doubt
PayPal honey no doubt are we all set sir
yes sir let's move on
no doubt oh this is actually you sir
PlayStation VR2 what what happened yeah
man like oh well the the the verdict is
out uh psvr2 reviews are in initial
reviews for uh the first batch of games
are also in and for the most part it's
kind of overwhelmingly positive I think
uh in terms of the tech most people feel
that the tech is really good I saw some
early uh sort of comparisons in the week
before actually the review started
coming out and they were saying that
there were games running at a steadier
clip on psvr then on PC with a 3090 TI
yeah so I was like okay there is really
something to uh you know a bespoke sort
of closed ecosystem of being the focus
and work on that particular thing and
kind of optimizing it as much as
possible so again I already I checked my
order mine is is in route already it's
shipped so maybe I will get it uh you
know maybe a day early maybe I'll get it
tomorrow
um but I'm excited to try it out you
know I know that we talked about the the
potential that you know their
projections for how many they'd be able
to sell off the rip were you know and
they they challenged those sort of
projections but the fact that that they
may not be able to sell as many as they
wanted to and had they sort of passed
the point where VR uh as a tech that
that could that could be as big as
people expected it to be or we sort of
past that point but I will say this I'm
just I've been really impressed with
what everybody's had to say about it
Tech wise um the last thing you want is
to buy something brand new and for it to
be behind the eight ball already right
and be and be this sort of
this this thing that is not at the cusp
of of where the text should be so I'm
excited that it's it's up there right um
and I'm also what I'm worried about and
I think we all discussed this is just
the fact that you know apart from you
know uh call of the mountain and maybe
one or two other things there isn't a
lot in that launch lineup that's that I
haven't played elsewhere
um that I don't know that the extra
Fidelity is necessarily going to make
you know that big of a difference and I
really want to see if PlayStation is
going to double down and make some games
and make this give people a real reason
internally as PlayStation fans to care
about the psvr too so I'm excited but
again a little tentative as well I want
to know what you guys stand with this
resident VR expert
man it's a sin to talk about the BR
apparently uh I have no interest in VR
whatsoever uh you know the only thing
that really got me even remotely
interested was uh you know the Quest 2
it got me a little bit you know curious
about the VR world uh but you know I got
obliterated for uh for for my opinions
on VRT so I'm I'm gonna crawl up in my
shell
yeah so I I I'm gonna I'm gonna stay in
here man I stand down you know I'd
rather play Tetris before I play VR but
that's besides Sports wow
wow interesting because demio came out I
don't need I don't need the VR right now
you know okay I want one of these places
to show me like a lot of games that make
me want to play a VR and right now I
haven't really seen that yeah fair
enough for you uh Lord King you have
thoughts okay well um I have put out the
I think it was last week I told people
you know last week I was in here it's a
week before that and I told people yo um
I have three statues if you know
somebody wanna come up off that they can
give sixteen hundred dollars worth of
statues for the PlayStation VR because
I'm not gonna give them my bread and um
then I had somebody hit me up in my DMs
and they was like oh you know um what
about that Green Lantern because he
wanted the Green Lantern statue I had I
said no I've been purged myself of the
DC stuff you know um I just got you know
the Marvel statues but then I forgot I
have a whole bunch of DC uh stuff
upstairs so again I'm putting this out
there for anybody get those statues
that's available
um and and I go into it saying this once
10 cent shut down
their VR uh engagement
as far as uh manufacturing a headset or
making video games or whatever that they
were going to do they canceled that they
was like no because the sustainability
of VR in this environment is not going
to be viable it's a it's a very small
Niche ceiling for this thing and I've
always said this that the PlayStation
VR2 feels like a niche uh passion
project for somebody that's there I
don't know who got this thing green lit
but from what I've saw with the reviews
the single wire like this wire that I
have here uh runs to it and opposed to
the cumbersome uh convoluted thing of
the payus VR1 and the move controllers
which wasn't designed for it but it did
convey a certain level of uh immersion
in it I like the PlayStation VR one I
thought the PlayStation VR1 had a better
launch lineup to begin with and I
thought it had the ability to go further
so it did have a better launch lineup it
did have other games that was with it uh
even though it was like half baked
because of the camera was made for the
move stuff a lot of stuff was
Frankenstein together it managed to sell
5 million and I know the thought process
is the PlayStation VR2
it's not Frankenstein it's something to
start out it was something that was made
for the PlayStation 5. that's I.E no
back compat no excuse
um no bad compat more reasons to gouge
the public again
but they have to sell this thing right
I feel it's DOA
not saying it is bad Tech
not saying that it's not transformative
in the controls everybody I saw said the
headset was more comfortable it was
lighter if you believe it than the
PlayStation VR1 and it had more Tech
inside right uh the controllers was made
from the ground up for this so this is a
a console because it's a separate
console made specifically for a target
audience and the games aren't there
Call of the Wild gets a bit repetitive
uh in the climbing instance from
whatever everybody that I've seen I read
that yeah it's very very repetitive
whereas you after the first Mountain you
climb you're like yeah I did that but if
majority of the game 80 of the game is
you climbing mountains
um it's gonna get a little bit uh
repetitive so you need to have a
variation in the games that were
available now a lot of these games are
available on other platforms for cheaper
this is the part for cheaper where the
headset and there's no tethering is
cheaper this is a Discerning consumer
base now right do you go get a quest
with lower resolution so you can set up
anywhere in your house anywhere away
from your television so you're not
punching your television busting your
television up you're in the foyer you're
in the living room you're in the Attic
wherever you want to be with it you're
untethered right here you have to be in
this situation and it's 600 dollars
whereas the quest is cheaper the games
are cheaper I don't see the advantage
and don't tell me the 4K thing or per
eye is 2K man and I have 100 that
doesn't matter when you factor in the
limitations and The Limited software
that's available to you it doesn't show
the wherewithal and I don't believe Sony
can stomach the loss
so after a year I want to have the
question is it still around because we
know they give you the six to eight
months you gotta work You Gotta Sink or
Swim baby and then they walk away from
it but they act like you know they just
stop talking to it it's still there in
the house but Sony just like walks by
and like hmm
stops acknowledging the fact and I want
to see where's the God of War VR you did
Gran Turismo where's these games that
are readily available why aren't these
things at launch for this thing you mean
where's the Spider-Man where's the Iron
Man 2 where are these things that's
supposed to start selling this this
console to the to the people and this is
the reason why you took a million loss
you step back and said first it was 2
million now we're gonna we our
projections is a million that doesn't
sound good from the rip I'm sorry
okay get smoking okay guys thoughts
thank you for ruining
keeping my height number by pre-order
right right in the toilet Buzz arrives
you know next week and uh look we saw
the reviews mostly positive
um the tech looks promising you know I'm
allowed to say that yeah
no I'm about to say that look you know I
I will say only got different I do like
the launch lineup I feel like um you
know for out to Kingsport yes there are
people who have played a lot of those
games other places we get it you know
all questions other things but you know
there's going to be some people who win
the PlayStation ecosystem that have
never that will give VR a try so there's
a part of me that wants to see you know
how that does for them as far as the
engagement the attachment rate and that
kind of stuff and then um you know we
got to give credit where credit is do as
far as you know their first party lineup
so the hope is you know obviously we see
called the mountain you know they're
known for the Boombastic AAA first party
experiences you know the hope is you
know they will translate that into VR as
well so and you ain't even alloy though
true you know I know I know where you
going with quality regular dude and she
come walking past like oh I see you in
my game
you came to the Big Show you are a
little sideball oh wow
how you gonna have a sideboard game give
you a side ball
I mean we gotta we gotta kick it to him
listen I I rather I'm tired of Eloy so
let's see
look you know what I'm saying look we
got to see how that plays out into the
overall Canada you know so maybe that's
what decision did but I do want to see
if they leverage these huge IPS that
they have yeah
you know what I'm saying you know um
Last of Us you know there's a lot of us
you know what that last time no no no
because they're gonna see that's in
round two no Go remix one and put it
look you know we gotta see we got to see
if they leverage it and that so that's
where I'm at the only thing I will say
is the best people to give you games I
will say for a VR is a console
manufacturer because they understand how
important games are
yeah it'll be good to see them in the
space to see what obviously they don't
understand how important games are
because they didn't give you no damn
games
take out take this passion project jump
the week
they didn't even put the main character
that's like playing Kratos playing God
of War and you were ogre
like you play the ogre side quests
how how can you tell me how much you
don't really respect your product not
even
main character in yo this that's when I
knew because that's what you do
have no faith in your own product
there's no y'all did not attach nobody
to it yes sir hmm what game can we throw
out there somebody said call it a while
I keep saying
they said what the hell is that he said
yo I have this little thing that I
curated that's about Horizon oh okay not
the main character right he said yeah
all right that'll work so
put Calvin in he like
so you get a chance to control Calvin
and he runs away from Renegade robots
you know put that in there he said okay
so we're gonna do the God of War he said
yo man if you don't get the hell out of
my office
you're messy bro yeah
[Laughter]
respect the product How You Gonna not
respect it you didn't put this is the
first time this is like launching a
console and don't put no mascot this is
how I knew Virtual Boy was gonna be
trash right because
and
[Laughter]
[Music]
call it
[Laughter]
this is the the wicked step cousin of
the place
beside me was like well let's see if it
Fly though how you gonna let it fly if
you ain't giving no wings you just throw
it out the window
it said fly baby fly it's nothing there
there's no sustainability there and
these guys keep talking about but it's
4K in each eye you ain't seen anything
yo yo what's up with somebody DM me it
was like the God of War VR game is you
play as mamir and you just hanging off
you hanging off of cradles just wait and
wait you get to see cradle's butt all
day again
Xbox podcast yeah yeah clearly remember
these are the kids
these are the people that's hyped for a
600 joint with no games man
y'all bugged out crazy yeah so that
kills the enthusiasm but your BSR will
be checking it out exactly real soon so
I got my notifications I could be back
on Quest too
hit me up would love to trade uh Tessa
cross play you know
he's gonna laugh at you
I've been laughing [__] is gonna laugh
at you he's gonna laugh look play
Playstation for your owners get a chance
to play with your mps5 you don't have VR
PS5 has the demio shout out to
PlayStation for this because Xbox you
got to get on this like they got DME
over the PC version like but for the
console so you don't need VR as well and
we can do that cross play y'all make
their own joint obsolete
that's how you know they don't really
respect it
and if you don't have VR you can still
play it this is the best thing
away from you they don't like you at all
oh my God flush it flush the toilet bowl
listen watch your money go down the
trailer
yo use the honey app
yo hopefully you can get some money off
you are so messy right now anyways
that's all I got
I'm gonna move on before I can't
continue to get more bars
we can combine it if you want you know
it's up to y'all unless we got super
chats we gotta get well it's just for
Action yeah just be quiet there's
nothing else to come on I'm crying with
you yeah so look man we already know
what most of us know what happens
um shout out to forax's games um put out
a statement you know recently again the
legendary Jake Solomon and I believe
also uh Studio head should I find a
gentleman's name here uh Steve
uh Steve Martin that's funny yeah so
after 27 years I hit 32 Plus game
releases he's leaving for Access games
and Studio head I'm tremendously
grateful for the opportunity of champion
led the work of such talented groups
people in the past couple of decades I'm
proud of the legacy of games for Access
has created its reputation in the
industry I still look forward to
cheering off for access in its next
chapter stay civilized obviously what is
one's responsible for the civilization
series and stuff like that and then this
one gets close to home for me and
addicts you know Jake Solomon you know
one of the legendary term-based
producers x-com SOB's favorite Xbox my
favorite yeah after 23 years he's moving
on from paraxis he's a big dreamer he
fulfilled two lifelong dreams of making
x-com XCOM 2 and water chosen that's my
favorite too and Marvel's midnight Sons
I'm the luckiest kid who ever lived XCOM
was my favorite game growing up it's why
I became a developer Marvel Comics made
me a dreamer and those characters are
like feel like my extended family I'm
grateful to Sid first and foremost for
teaching me and then he goes on to say
he's grateful for 2K you know he's
thankful for everyone that enjoyed XCOM
and midnight Sons you never take it for
granted he's um now for letting him do
his job and he said his brain is on fire
with a new dream time to go chase it so
basically you know two major pivotal
players you know after leaving for
Access
um right after you know midnight Suns
and we know the story of midnight Suns
it was not a commercial success you know
the heads of 2K came out and said you
know they were disappointed and that
maybe they put some blame on themselves
with um the release date being at
December so you know this is cog's
emotional moment and you know obviously
I'm a huge fan of the turnbage genre I
don't want it to go away my concern was
that you know we didn't have they didn't
do x-com three they they got the Marvel
bags big IP they put it out it didn't do
well it's already now on sale discounted
and it's already uh demo trial demos
available so I just wanted to you know
bring it to the realm you know one do we
think the turn-based genre is is in
serious trouble because as much as I
love it right we have to admit there's
guys like solve this guy's like you know
King sometimes like oh whoever who just
like look I love these type of games I
mean I don't like these type of games
like Marvel the characters but I may
never play them in that you know mode
and then the second thing is like and
I'm just kind of thinking like do you
think it behooves
for Axis or turn base or RTS guys to
kind of try to get a Game Pass back so
that maybe you get the virality of being
in a service like that to kind of stick
around because maybe the genre is just
not hitting we know it's hitting
for PC
right PC seems to be the place these
genres live but maybe console gamers are
just not giving my beloved turn base so
I'm giving to you at it because uh this
is his home for us and even though
you're a Dexcom guy you didn't really
like midnight Suns like that either so I
know so yeah so let's talk about you
know these two departures in the future
of turn base
I think the issue I I think you know
I hope Jake finds uh success it seems
like he's gonna
develop his own studio uh that that's
that's what's being conveyed to me I
don't know if that it goes through with
that or not but you know the the good
thing about it is
I don't think that this is going to you
know determine whether or not turn base
is successful like this isn't just a
turn-based game it's a card based combat
with turn-based mechanics and you know
people don't like to play the card stuff
in general people don't like to play
turn based in general so you put them
together you know I know people like BG
that really loved XCOM and you know when
it came to midnight Suns he was like me
he's like I just I'm not feeling the
card based uh combat you know we
expected more of an ex-con traditional
with the Marvel characters and even
though I don't think that would have
worked out entirely to its core I do
feel like they could have found a way to
make it work uh you know I I hope that
that you know they make XCOM 3 and I
hope you know turn base still go because
you see you see games like fire them do
well you know Mario rabbits so pretty
good so I don't think that the the genre
is dead I just I feel like you know they
need an IP behind rabbits rabbits too
flopped
oh rabbit's too flopped yeah it flopped
yeah yeah rabbits too that's why I'm
bringing this up I'm just scared y'all
like this is my phone rapping still I
mean yeah with a Mario license I wanted
to play that game
I guess dropping it around the time that
it is yeah I think it might go up sales
might pick up when Zelda comes out
right because a lot of people like
myself are sitting on the background
waiting for Zelda or something like that
something really big to pull you right
back into the to the ecosystem I know
other people have Pokemon and stuff like
that and I think that's very specific
I do want to play that game and knowing
how Nintendo ever put games on sale and
ever wish for it to go on sale I know
it's not going to happen so I'll
probably get in then but um yeah that's
that sucks I thought that that thing
would have sold because I know the first
one was such a great thing the problem
is is
that genre's Niche and I I think that
people like for Access have cracked the
barrier in some way shape or form
because x-com both xcoms did well so
it's just like look like you you need a
platform like an x-com you need an
audience like XCOM and I truly believe
that a lot of x-com people just looked
at that uh you know midnight Suns is
like that just doesn't look like
something I Vibe with you know when you
isolate the community that built You by
doing something so drastic
you're I think at that point you're
tossing a coin hoping that you get the
best possible outcome and unfortunately
it didn't look like they got the outcome
that uh would have been better for them
no doubt solve your favorite job Return
base
no but I don't think I don't hate it
like I used to see that was the very
particular thing
oh he's just sit in the background like
damn it you know I was I used to you're
just gonna understand when I'd come over
I'm like all right we're gonna get this
Halo on we got this wrestling on or
attacking we playing oh yeah we playing
XCOM
yeah I'll be over here I'll be over here
with my PSP thank you very much
but I will say Mario Rabbids the first
one brought me into the fold I was like
you know what I'm gonna try this
foolishness because
okay the thing was I was like
so I'm like wait a minute let me just
let me see and the thing about that was
good is like it had all of the all of
the check marks when it comes to you
know true hardcore right uh turn based
stuff but it had the cutesiness of and
and for me it was like okay it allowed
me to sort of get into it without
feeling too pressure because I remember
you guys always talking about OverWatch
and your characters are dying and that's
it and they're like oh I don't know I
just I I it never I just never
gravitated to it but that game got me
interested I'm like okay and see what's
funny is those key features and those
key you know uh gameplay mechanics is I
believe the reason it didn't succeed
because when people play these type of
games they do expect that management uh
behind closed doors they do expect the
OverWatch type of Fatality and the you
know because I remember one uh
x-com Primera Squad came out it was a
huge thing why you couldn't name
character couldn't name characters I
remember that people expect that type of
gameplay all out of these type of games
that I think the reason that some of
these games are doing it aren't
succeeding it's because obviously if you
use a Marvel IP characters aren't going
to die like that so we're doing that I
do want to push back on one aspect of
what y'all said I'll get right back to
you in the sense of
um you know remember like even the best
the ones we consider the best like shout
out to my man uh one bad mother he
mentioned x-comp 2 water chosen like I
remember the ports to to console would
take like a year yeah before we come
over like it's almost like they were not
confident that the bag could be secured
you know or maybe they had the metrics
to say hey when you brought it on
Console it ain't really doing the
numbers like that and then let's be
honest at a camera Squad never even came
to console still so there's got to be
some trepidation with bringing these
games to console and I'm just worried
that the genres it might
if you want to play this genre you might
get some of the some that leaks through
the cracks but the majority of them are
on PC and if you want to really play
this brand like the uh the uh the Met
games there's a lot of other games it's
not XCOM that do very well on me yeah
and the problem is is when you put these
kind of games on on Console besides like
Halo Wars the original one it's very
hard to sell very hard to sell but you
know the crazy thing is that you know
it's funny because I I had this issue
with XCOM but then I love Final Fantasy
Tactics though
maybe it was the aesthetic thing where I
wasn't as big into the Sci-Fi at that
point and I just it just didn't but you
know
yeah and then I remember
um when attic was playing felsil he was
like yo this fell seal it was crazy and
I was like okay I downloaded it yeah and
fell seal is kind of amazing so it I
mean the thing about it is it's the
close this is thing you'll have to taxes
actual tactic system yeah so so for me
it's like
I don't see it going away I do
and this is going to be sacrileged to
you purists but maybe maybe find this
middle ground in it like when you look
at when you look at what they did with
ff7 remake and the the middle ground
between the turn-based Tactical and just
straight up Combat Action and the Combat
Action the valkyrie Chronicles is all
they already do that so yeah so it's
just gonna be a matter I think if they
had done something of that nature but
speaking specifically not a midnight
Sons right I think the card stuff
whether it's cool or not threw a lot of
people off and they either expect it
they either were expecting or hoping for
a straight up x-com type without that
extra you know with the card system or
like I was saying like the ff7 like
something that felt more actiony where
it felt like you had more control over
the character directly
um but also gave you that strategy
underneath like underlying layer
strategy where it was like okay
um positioning and all this stuff
matters OverWatch matters but I could
control the character more directly yeah
when you think about how you want to the
fact of the matter is when you think
about Marvel properties and comic book
properties a lot of people just when
they when you hear that they think about
a third person action game because it's
like okay I want to be able and have to
inhabit this hero and play them and
control them and feel like I'm I am that
hero absolutely I remember not to cut
you but I remember that was the feeling
when John Wick hex got announced
right and it was awesome but it was also
that thing was like damn like you didn't
give me the action game with John Wick
where it slows down like a mer and do
all this hot stuff the closest thing to
John Wicked Seafood yes without without
the guns right Xbox one better support
that don't be mad at y'all so I don't
think what do you think about the Josh
Sawyer departure
listen that man is is made the
soundtrack to the streets as far as I'm
concerned like you know he's a legend
and he took I want to give um what's his
name my man I think his name Julian
Gallup the OG that made x-com right
don't get me wrong I want to respect him
he now has Phoenix point he's a legend
but when Solomon came like he's the nas
to the Rock camp
came out at those x-coms is is god tier
like the Edge Story bass level every
full package right when I see him leave
Studio head leave it's just called I
have no inside information to me that is
you're being blamed
for this the lack of the success someone
right someone's heads got to I get I
have no I could be wrong but the way I
internalize it is like it's like when
the 343 situation right right somebody
got to pay we this is somebody's dream
we had these projections for this this
Marvel license right we expected big
numbers it didn't hit now Studio head
because I feel it convenient to be like
oh by the way guys don't worry
simulations new civilization gets carbon
which is the big thing right right
that's the offset the panic in the
building and I think this is my Cog
opinion I could be wrong that dudes are
being the bigger man and be like okay
we're stepping down yeah you know what
I'm saying but you the studio head and
Solomon leave at the same time to me is
a red flag so I gotta see how they move
forward now I hear some Rumblings in the
building like calm down it's not open
Gloom the way you think it is this thing
is still cooking but I just think well
maybe the midnight Sons thing was you
know what I'm saying step on the grenade
yeah somebody had to pay
it makes sense again you get the first
time a game like this gets a Marvel
license you're hoping for a big success
and you make you make a good game you
make you arguably a great game now we're
gonna have a conversation
we're gonna have a conversation okay
all right so we know you know um it
didn't look visually like how it should
have okay you know um I think uh some of
the designs on the characters could have
been a little bit different not saying
that they weren't true to what their
Vision was but the PlayStation 3
Graphics really that's fair that's good
that's you know that's really a pushback
now are we at the point now where you
don't slap Marvel's name on it and think
it's going to uh you know sell
gangbusters are we there yet did we not
learn already from Marvel Avengers uh
with the nif nod costumes and and
characters that weren't comic books
are you the same person that attacked me
because of Star Wars a couple weeks ago
oh why why did gay dude look because the
Stars Star Wars but I think I think
there's something to be said about like
what I said when you play a superhero
game you want a third person action game
and all you can even just one uh just
one for sure
and the reason and the reasons
in case you didn't know now quit now
this is this is the caveat right right
when you look at Guardians right
Guardians is that but Guardians did I
think the the Fatal era of Guardians is
a great game
behind Avengers right and and the
Guardians wasn't it was kind of a hybrid
of that it's like oh yeah you can
control your other teammates but you're
a Star-Lord if you're not a Star-Lord
fan you're stuck playing a Star-Lord and
you gotta play that everything is on the
game so amazing it's a dope game
but again
can't slap Marvel name on the thing is
going to win now this game really we
already first of all it's a niche type
of game this genre is not for everybody
I'm not gonna stop after like y'all was
out here selling all these games to
these people no okay
I understand but we was the ones that
were playing it right so now that we got
the situation why didn't you put it in
Game Pass
oh cause your head was too big you said
now we have the definitive formula our
formula is lit we are the best in this
formula all we need to do is slap Marvel
on it and it's going to sell gangbusters
uh news flash fool
you should have went and put it in the
service you should have teamed up you
should have took you should have tucked
your tail between your legs and say
because I know more I know uh
Playstation probably came at you
I know Microsoft probably came at you
Game Pass dudes try yeah yeah we try I
don't think 2k's ever really put games
in their day NBA 2K has been engaged NBA
2K
sometime in the year I think
the fact that it's a niche genre
you should have put in the game pass and
then you should have been able to sell
all your you could have nickeled and
dimed them the DLCs and the characters
yes especially with the characters
especially with the characters all day
you messed up the bag and in doing so
you you drag uh great people down with
you this I don't I don't put it on the
studio heads
I put it on the publisher and I put it
on the the company heads they did take
responsibility they said they they think
they made a mistake with the December
yeah but they ain't quitting
they think they made a mistake with the
December release date yeah they said it
publicly they said they try to take the
some of the bullet yeah we take the
bullet but we gonna point we gonna push
them out the door we you didn't take a
cut in your pay to make sure that he
stayed on you didn't come out and put
out a public uh apology to the
development uh heads you didn't say oh
no they did a fantastic job we just
messed up marketing we just messed up
placement we just messed up timing you
didn't say that because it's a great
game otherwise so who else is the
problem is the people that was
distributed it publishing it and placing
it so marketing suck the Distributing
sucked now that marketing was is a lot
of marketing games
but here's the thing though here's the
thing even if you put that in Game Pass
if you put that PlayStation Plus you put
that at epic game store that's only
going to generate a certain amount of
money this is Marvel licensing we're
talking about probably three to four
years of of development like I don't
think they were going to get that back
and I'm gonna tell you
you start placing that game inside Game
Pass and PlayStation Plus and epic store
wherever and you drop out iconic
characters
for the sale for the two dollars here
all right two dollars I just picked up a
skin the other day just because it was
Piccolo I said oh
what this is it's different though it's
no different if you come over there and
you know because you can age the thing
the thing about fortnite is you can show
off in fortnite I got this skin I got
that that's a single play again there's
no multiplayer every time you literally
buying stuff you're like yo that's gold
so so can if fortnite was a single
player game and you bought that and you
couldn't show that to anyone you
couldn't want that out to anyone you're
gonna buy Piccolo yo
I'm guilty of getting what I want um
I'm that dude I don't care literally I
don't care I don't care who's playing
around nothing I told people all day
long I don't care who sells all I want
is Naruto that's all I wanted right but
if you had if you had a game
where if even if a single player and you
can change their skin to whatever you
know the people that absolutely you're
gonna do it absolutely not that's you
but me they're getting my two dollars I
was just talking to Cog like where's my
dad how do I get it because I paid for
it well because you paid for it it's not
like they're actually what how much
how much stuff Have you bought on
Destiny it's
a player aspect what did you buy on
anything else that's not a multiplayer
aspect did you buy anything on Marvel
Avengers
first of all when you have my man with a
broken collarbone and all that stuff
Spiderman for me
in that game I purchased the Mr Fix-it
costume I purchased the Gladiator Hulk
costume I purchased stuff that mattered
to me now ask me do I play with anybody
in the game hell today I don't care but
again it boils down to
how the game was distributed I'm saying
this that game being in it if you if
you're going to take the hubris out of
remove the hubris
and I know you got to make back the
money off the licensee Microsoft bag up
front would have got you halfway there
you better get a security for sure yeah
Sony's uh bag would have got you halfway
there you know so you you yeah but we we
gotta we gotta consider that most the
time when one of them sign you for
something like that six months from now
on track they saying you can't go on the
other guy yeah we double back later we
we be you look at whoever the market
leader is right
the games don't really have that
longevity like that like it's so you got
to look when it comes to gaming it's a
very fast tsunami but this time next
week everything we play now for the most
part ever will be moved on to the next
thing uh so let me ask you a question
addict and you owning the company right
do you say all right um Game Pass has
the most engagement we can take the bag
from Game Pass and we can put the game
in there and we can sell it every place
else or or you say to hell with all of
that the hell with the security let's
just put this game out there and let's
let's go get it because you know we we
we got the best product I can't like
speak on like you know if I was in that
scenario I would be a different person
entirely like if I had my mindset I
probably would have built the game
differently than try to sell it no but
to me like just like that it's hard to
take something like the Marvel IP and
say let's go to Game Pass like you got
the Marvel IP probably coming off of
like the greatest movie sets that's ever
been like that scene at the end game
where everyone came in that's probably
the greatest moment and and not right in
movie history and it's hard to sit there
and have those type of characters in
your hand and say yo
we're going to believe in ourselves you
got probably one of the best most iconic
characters in your hand and I have the
hard to believe that they didn't think
that that was gonna maybe maybe they
thought this was going to be the thing
to bring that turn based through because
listen they didn't do x-com three in
this place there's no reason why they
didn't tell you it was cards until later
yeah it's a reason listen stop stop
acting like you didn't know they were
very upfronted
now did the cards maybe because you
didn't let it go but the concept
actually simplify the game for people
who feels
exactly complicated I don't like the
card aspect but I'm not going to say
they were B they were being like
deceiving they was like midnight check
us out there
remember dudes like oh my God it's
garbage I can't try to act like they
were doing some [__] business
[Applause]
it was normal
OverWatch
we're gonna place it we gonna do this
and then when they said and then the
card system
a little bit more traditional XCOM style
gameplay they would have got people like
me BG and yeah
if it would have sold like tremendously
or anything like that but I personally
feel like
I know I think I know what other mistake
is and we know it wasn't really a lot of
people talk about it let's just say they
believed it so much they either won the
gay pass bag or whatever PlayStation
Plus bag would have been big enough I
think the mistake that they made is do
you know this is not available or switch
day one the twitch version is still
coming I think they missed out by not
having the switch also so it was coming
in hot then yes which is still coming
later it's still it's still could have
come in hard man
the graphics to that game little
suspects I mean you yourself said it
looked like a mobile game so clearly the
boy can't be that so maybe it could even
that game probably would have a hard
time running on the switch
can't get on my nerves
no it's just that I think the game would
have did fantastic inside a Game Pass
environment being that it's a niche game
these guys was too high on a hog with
the fact that they had the Marvel
license and they was like yo we got the
best formula we're gonna put some Marvel
characters
and yo I know the card system they threw
that out there the dude is like I'm not
feeling I'm gonna Bureau of you guys we
got five minutes to close yeah we gotta
go look so look midnight Suns is lit go
play is a free demo out right now on
PlayStation and Xbox and steam check it
out try it see what it is and I agree
with King that arm look PlayStation 3K
humble yourself if possible put it in
Game Pass or whatever they do it when
the price drops and and and repackage it
with DLC Jake sawman I see you brother
do your thing I'm looking to see what
you got cookies
let me see
I get to knee remember for one year five
dollars I can see I can see the
negotiations with security we need you
to protect saab's joystick okay let's
play with each other
we're gonna put a chastity belt on them
it there we have let me play with Kings
joysters yeah
lighter comfortable and better Tech
inside like King yeah
have you noticed black attic and white
[__] he's been in my April
that'll be good there we haven't let me
play no no we have Lawrence Davenport
remember for two months five dollars in
the chat I think Marvel's been nice sons
and evil West are good games were
released at the wrong time
that's valid ready that's it all right
pole like do uh pole is up with
third-party Game Pass uh which which
third party Xbox game pass game do you
think will cannibalize sales get
generate the most increase the
subscriber once it hits the service the
choices are a atomic heart B MLB the
show 23. King like that one
whoa long Fallen Dynasty and D no messy
Lords lots of people yeah
um which four of those do you think will
maybe Carolina's kind of ourselves but
do the most increase to game passes I'm
curious which way it kind of feel it
kind of feels like the Souls game right
there the two Souls games right the two
Souls games right we'll see which one of
them is better uh foreign
we did that today I gotta celebrate oh
man we celebrate us we did that today
oh we got three minutes oh because of
the premium
yo Cliffy B the legend salute that was
fantastic
an amazing interview he was so he was so
transparent and he gave us the bars and
he actually respected the road which you
know we thought about a bit hard you
know Facebook we did this thing and
again we're going to do what we're doing
at it right after this ends the
legendary straight into uh the higher
five Rush high five Rush interview the
Lord secured it John Johannes we sit
down with the Legend So if you missed it
in the pre-show we're gonna send it
right after this right now you're gonna
go get that yeah the whole interview is
great the whole interview's great and
even if you watch it go over there and
give us a like man yeah go ahead my
joystick
though shout out to you I wasn't able to
be there but it's a fantastic interview
fantastic you catch me on Twitter
this Tuesday
last thing for me
yes
save us some money it's pinned to the
chat man go save some money Lord Metro
two dollar Super Chat yeah I did
yourself fellas thank you very much love
y'all blessings
thank you bro thank you good night peace
[Music]
thank you